so chat, auf gehts, so ein bisschen hacker manns machen wieder
ist die auch horizontal scalable ja habe ich noch nicht den passenden enabler
für gefunden so also ich zeige euch mal was wir heute machen vielleicht war das
mal ein bisschen stream on ist aber beim titel steht ja schon holkorn mischbrot
elf monate excellent subscription iq increase also was wir heute machen ist
folgendes wir mieten uns in hetzener server und schieben mal mein mein test 360
ti stock tracker drauf ich habe das ich habe ich habe hat vormittag so ungefähr
13 uhr bis jetzt 13 bis so 16 30 habe ich da dran rumgebastelt der kann
ehrlich gesagt noch nix aber die basis funktioniert zumindest schon mal aber
da kann der kann zumindest 360 ti schon mal 360 ti schon mal tracken ob die
verfügbar sind das ganze sieht dann so aus können es dann nachher auch selbst
ausprobieren wenn ihr wollt ja weil aktuell mal gucken was geiz halt sagt
also aktuell ist nicht wirklich was available gucken wir mal ob geiz als da
was anders sieht doch ihr guckt mal ja aber die sind nicht wirklich available
die sind ebay ja ebay habe ich nicht drinne so kraft dreck ich net also ich
zeige schon wieder das ganze aussieht der track was man tracken will der track
case king minefactory alternate alles mögliche das tracking an sich mache ich
nicht selbst ich habe bloß das web interface gebastelt weil warum soll ich
das alles noch mal neu programmieren wenn es funktioniert aber wir richten
das jetzt zusammen ein vor allem ich mache mir halt eine domain wo man den
kram darunter erreichen kann deswegen habe ich jetzt auch nur wirklich die
absoluten basics programmiert das ist ja eh das wichtigste das wissen wir ja
von youtube 2020 damit muss man anfangen und der kann wie gesagt aktuell außer
ein grünes fenster anzeigen im browser wenn es irgendwo verfügbar ist mit dem
link auf den store noch absolut gar nichts ich zeige euch einmal wie das
ganze aussieht
ich zeige euch mal wie das ganze aussieht ich habe es hier ausgecheckt das
ganze nennt sich preisschamp ich weiß ich werde immer kreativer mit meinen
namen der preisschamp ist am start und wenn
wir das jetzt starten dann gehen wir mal auf die seite dann steht einfach nur da
das da so und im hintergrund wird getrackt also jetzt gerade nicht aber
das geht schon das richten wir auch gleich ein
und dann wenn das verfügbar ist das habe ich schon ausprobiert das probieren wir
nachher auch aus ihr könnt es dann auf der webseite ausprobieren kommt dann
halt anscheinend roter button ein grüner button mit link zum shop das ist
bedienbar noch nicht sonderlich gut aber erst mal das was oben ist und dass es
funktioniert mir geht es jetzt hauptsächlich erst mal darum das
einzurichten dass dass ich das irgendwie automatisch auf den server schieben kann
dass ich gültiges zertifikat habe dass ich bin server miete und so probieren wir
mal aus
360 soll Mitte Februar kommen ist ja perfekt wenn man da jetzt schon den 360
e-tracker hat gab es nicht letzten schon welche
gab es nicht letzten schon welche
oder zum vorbestellen gab es nicht letzten schon was zum vorbestellen
ps5 PS 5 kann der auch tracken der kann für es PS 5 tracken
Dings tracken ich verwende dafür zum also zum tracken verwende ich das hier
aber
ist in cobalt programmiert zum tracken verwende ich das hier
wow oder fack sieht es so kacke aus ach so weil da ok zum tracken verwende ich
den kram hier der kann alle möglichen stores und ich hänge mich da dran und
machen web interface
Patrick hast du dabei schon software as a service und infrastructure as
eine plattform bedacht ich frag nur einfach mal
germane prime dankeschön und ist es auch hyper agile und hast du die passenden
enabler schon kontaktiert dafür weil wir sollten eine
innovations offensive starten finde ich oder meinst du nicht auch also ich glaube
ich glaube so eine innovations offensive muss man sein
innovations password offensive den cloud architekt brauchen wir auch noch
genau also das ding verwende ich ich zeige euch ich zeige euch wie es
funktioniert das ist easy also das ding verwende ich das macht es tracking und
ich habe mein meine anwendung also die hier die die preis champ anwendung die
guckt im hintergrund nach das wird im hintergrund
ups fack kriegt im hintergrund in notification geschickt wenn wenn der hier
was gefunden hat also es ist relativ easy ich zeige euch das gleich aber wir
mieten uns erstmal den server installieren den kram machen zertifikat
und sowas das wird eine richtig destruktive technologie aber bin ich aber
bin ich beruhigt
also jetzt 30 60 die wieso nicht das kann alles mögliche später tracken das
kann später das wird ein web interface für dieses ding also die können aktuell
tracken 30 60 5900 die reisen dinger die können das ding kann total viel
tracken weil ich zeige euch das ich zeige euch das mal ich zeige euch das
mal
zeige ich selbst mal lokal bevor wir das bei hetzner machen so npm
was muss man mpmi das ist ja ach ich habe kein npm installiert geht das
überhaupt kamen überhaupt not installieren ohne npm
ernsthaft geht das sich gar nicht war mir so jetzt nicht bewusst dass das
überhaupt möglich ist j ist der paket manager für user repos jetzt jetzt geht
das das teil kann sogar pf5 ja das kann also das ding kann zeige ich mal wie
gesagt ich verwende nicht das web interface davon ich habe ein eigenes
gebastelt das ist nur unter der haufe fürs tracking da das ding kann aktuell
hier füllt ok ich muss man den dark reader ausmachen der nervt mich gerade
das ding kann 30 60 37 38 30 90 reisen 5600 5800 5900 5950 x 60 80
playstation digital edition und und dings gedöns classic oder was das ist
und die xbox also die allerwichtigsten sachen kann das ding nur dass das halt
kein gescheites web interface hat deswegen habe ich gedacht machen wir das
mal so hat es jetzt installiert so dann hat man hier einen konfig datei das
machen aber alles auf dem server und kann da gedöns eintragen was man was
man haben will zum beispiel wo man notifications haben will so und wir
machen notifications da drüber mein server hat das hat einen mqtt server am
start und da kriegt er immer notifications geschickt wenn sachen
verfügbar sind schreibt sich das lokal in sqleit datenbank und wenn jemand die
website aufmacht kauft camp org nenn ich kauf camp price camp fuck
preis camp so rum so viel camp dann zeigt einfach die aktuelle sachen an
das heißt es muss sich auch keiner selbst installieren kann sich das da
einfach angucken genau so und standardmäßig checkt es
glaube ich amazon und uac weil es halt kokona style ist das sieht dann so
aus wenn man startet ich hoffe das geht ohne dass ich eine konfig kopiert habe
so amazon best buy ist standardmäßig jetzt jetzt checkt er halt so vor sich
hin so und das ist natürlich schön wenn man das in der konsole sieht oder wenn
man browser fenster auf aufgemacht kriegt aber die meisten leute sind schon
mal allein schon gar nicht in der lage sich den kram hier zu installieren ich
habe halt ein schönes webinterface soll ich bauen schönes webinterface zu
aktuell kann es bloß 30 60 ti und 3 also 30 60 status tracken was wir machen ich
habe in den domain registriert für
ein hardware tracker der guckt was bei den shops verfügbar ist und das
richten wir heute ein so also hier hoch weiß gemp
noch mal zu zeigen wenn es dann wenn es dann später läuft bei hetzer sieht es
halt so aus und du siehst halt sobald eine 33 60 ti verfügbar ist ich habe
nichts an funktionen bisher eingebaut ich will einfach nur gucken ob das scheiß
funktioniert ob das auf dem server ordentlich läuft ob das tracked und im
hintergrund im hintergrund lasse ich schon alles mit mit in die datenbank
schreiben also ich werde playstation xbox und die ganzen reisen dinger
reinschreiben weil ich will eine preishistorie haben ich will eine
preishistorie haben und da schreibt alle fragt mir nicht alle 30 sekunden oder so
dann lokal in die datenbank rein was der findet und dann habe ich habe ich mal
kann ich mir eine schöne preishistorie auch noch machen aber erst mal zeigte
wer mit der preishistorie plus 360 ti an
weil das jetzt recht easy war da musste einfach nur ein button hin machen und
gut ist so wie gesagt das ist ich habe die basics eingebaut und die anderen
sachen erweitern geht dann eigentlich relativ easy so kann der poc dann erst
kommt das können wir alles machen wie wir lustig sind jetzt mit uns gehen wir
erstmal bei hetzer und mieten uns den server so hetzner easy
ach so moment ha null wie ist mein passport
mal ganz schnell in den passport champ gucken also login cloud
jetzt noch
klein number login was ist denn was ist denn das login die klein number
kenne ich aber was ist das login
mach lieber black screen ich gebe doch kein passport ein aber wir können
black screen doch wahrscheinlich kommen wir machen mal black screen falls ich
mich vertippe hast du eigentlich recht
man weiß ja nie na
ach du scheiß was habe ich da für nevig passport
dann hat keiner tippen was habe ich mir denn da ausgedacht
doch login excellent funktioniert
da ich mal wieder an
so da sind wir jetzt noch am start da war aktuell nix laufen auf dem account
zack neue server wo wollen wir hin
nachdem der kram überall gleich kostet hier nur nur im berg geben wir immer nur
ein berg besser sondern immer nur 2004 passt aber bitte kein twitch bot schreiben
plus 1000 bots hä verstehe ich nicht es lässt sich relativ einfach twitch bot
oder twitter bot basteln
leak
ach aus der suppe ja klar das ist das beste video max in der suppe also
21 04 brau war ja ja alles klar hier der der ver 296 im monat jawoll genau ist
das haki perfekt alles klar den brau war create
und bei excellent willst du dir eine 36 die kaufene aber ich will tracken ob es
die gibt ich will vor allem alles andere tracken und noch viel besser ich will
preishistorie haben das ist ein das ist war die ursprüngliche ideen ich meine
preishistorie mache zu dem ganzen zeug und da habe ich mir gedacht hey warum
baue ich nicht einfach eine seite mit ordentlichen webinterface wo leute sich
benachrichtigen lassen können wenn sachen zur verfügung stehen so die die
aktuell kann voll angesagt sind ich weiß dass es so ein paar sachen schon
gibt aber wer hat außer mir den poch am keks auf der seite allein schon deswegen
ist das besser so also guck mal mal der preischemp ssh bem nicht max gut wir
sind ruht erst mal update also sobald man sich nur bunto surfer anliegt erst
mal update immer update erst mal dann ist gut update upgrade reboot alles gut
und so die standardsachen können wir mal einmal installieren die ich mir
immer installiere erkennt mich ja schon das haben wir oft genug gemacht
wie viel kostet ein surfer also der kostet 2 euro 690 im monat das gute ist
an der hetzener cloud das ist ja seit ein paar jahren so im trend dass man das
ganze auch zeitzeit taktmäßig machen kann also wenn du den surfer plus zwei
minuten brauchst bezahlst du quasi nichts
lenny d3 ne da kann alle möglichen shops da kann ich nur new account amazon
das ist das was die fault drinne ist was auch gut ist weil die seiten können
viel ab und die leuten die leute die das programm einfach nur checken machen
dann nicht unnötig traffic auf allen möglich anderen seiten
der kann so ziemlich alles an deutschen shops von mediamarkt saturn bis
minefactory alternate case king computer uni wird die karikane eigentlich
so gut wie alles mögliche
ich kann euch mal zeigen was was das was das tracken kann das kann stores also
das ding kann akkord was auch immer das ist alternate amazon.de amd direkt case
king jetzt kann mehr oder weniger alles aber auch international also nicht nur
deutsche jobs als jobs shops lul weh wie viel traffic ist dabei das ist eine
gute frage keine ahnung ehrlich gesagt 20 g
alles 20 t ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
hetzner cloud pricing also mit 20 t komme ich ganz gut hin
prices hier da 20 terabyte traffic das reicht das da mal das reicht das mal
ach hier ne ach da guck mal hier das ist ja das reicht für ein bisschen web
requests machen so sieht es aus also installieren wir mal das zeug was ich
mir immer installier standardmäßig was schon alles drauf ist
alles klar gut so wie gut beste guck das ding installiere ich mir auch immer
zumindest unter allen Ubuntu Servern da kann man nicht aus versehen rebooten
was passiert wenn der traffic verbraucht ist du musst ex ne du das ist eine gute
frage ich weiß nicht ob du da nichts mehr machen kannst oder ob du zusatz
traffic kaufen muss das ist wahrscheinlich sehr ich hatte das
problem noch nie ich bin noch nie an die traffic grenzen gestoßen
wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich musst du dann extra traffic buchen oder was auch
immer keine ahnung da mache ich mir jetzt nicht so viel
gedanken wenn ich ehrlich bin so also das allerwichtigste wir haben wir machen
erst mal die firewall an so aber erst mal checken wir mal breitschamp.org ja gut
parkt also domain ist dns sind noch nicht eingerichtet ufw lau auf fakt ich kann
die ssh war das so ich benutze die ich benutze das benutze das so selten die
diese Ubuntu firewall von hand wie kommt man sich den kram noch mal anfangen
ne warte mal wie ging das noch mal wie konnte man sich die regel noch mal
anzahlen lassen numbered so was ok so jetzt haben wir ssh noch ufw default default deny und
jetzt enable s so wir haben uns nicht ausgesperrt das ist schon mal gut ssh ist
erlaubt alles klar so das ist das erste was ich mache ich
installiere so die standard pakete macht die Ubuntu firewall an und erlaubt
erst mal nur ssh da kann man erst mal nichts verkehrt machen und der server ist
jetzt auch dicht da tut sich jetzt erst mal nichts da können die da können die
russen und chinesen machen wie sie lustig sind das kriegst du nicht gebacken
so also jetzt erst mal die wichtigen sagen wir brauchen ein zertifikat du
änderst nicht direkt dann das kann ich auch machen aber jetzt erst mal nicht
genau jetzt muss ich mich erst mal bei meinem domain registrierungs mensch
einloggen und das mache ich aber nicht on stream weil ich nicht weiß ob da
email und adresse und was da alles genau drin steht
genau deswegen habe ich immer nur ssh key authentifizierung das ist das da
da musste die eigentlich jetzt nicht so viel gedanken machen es sei denn es sei
denn ssh halt halt so übelst grund übelst krass sicherheitslücke man kann
da viel machen wenn der tag lang ist man kann auch noch fail to ban und hast du
nicht gesehen alles installieren kann alles weil es gibt es gibt wir haben sogar
mal ein stream gemacht wo wir Ubuntu surfer abgesichert haben das spare ich
mir jetzt aber mal alles ich logg mich mal nebenbei
bei meinem domain registrer ein und muss die ip ändern im dns gucken wir
nämlich markt und preis jam punkt org wo kommen raus hier vier das ist falsch
wir müssen nämlich hier zu 188 da da müssen wir hin
gut das kann ich euch jetzt nicht zeigen wie ich den domain wie ich den dns
umstelle aber das ist auch kein großes ding also wenn ihr irgendwo eine domain
registriert habt da gibt es dns settings und da tragt ihr einfach die ip vom
server ein also das ist meistens ziemlich einfach
plus dass plus dass ich die seite nicht bedienen kann weil ich nur im hoch
format ab alter wo haben die denn den kack jetzt hier dns dns records da sind
war so wir machen eine domain beta punkt preis jam punkt org weil ich die
normale seite erst noch mal so lasse so wenn ich glück habe sollte das jetzt
schon ordentlich auflösen schauen wir mal beta punkt preis jam punkt
org da sind wir zack guck du wirst du was das coole ist jetzt kann man auf den
server drauf mit beta punkt preis jam punkt org alles klar es kommt natürlich
mal eine abfahre
jetzt brauchen wir erstmal ein zertifikat weil wenn wir im browser
drauf gehen also erstens läuft da noch nix wie man sieht und wir brauchen ein
gültiges zertifikat wenn es einfach sein soll nehme ich immer das ding
man kann sich es gibt also es gibt ganz viele varianten wie man sich zertifikat
machen kann wie man webserver betreiben kann wie man reverse proxy betreiben
kann und sonst was nur mal zur erklärung was wir jetzt machen also ich habe einmal
hier diese anwendung programmiert der preis jam das ist die dotnet anwendung die
läuft lokal auf port 5000 wie man hier sieht wenn ich die starte
seht also die anwendung hier ja genau die da die läuft lokal auf port 5000 das
macht die auch auf dem server wenn ich die da drauf schiebe lokal port 5000
bringt aber ja nix kann man ja nicht darauf zugreifen deswegen installiere ich
da drauf ein proxy der ist dafür da authentifizierung zu machen wenn man sie
benutzen will ich mache es ohne authentifizierung ich will das ganze
internet drauf zugreifen kann und der kümmert sich auch um zertifikate und der
leitet dann traffic der auf port 80 der auch der auch quasi auf der ap port 80
reinkommt leitet der um auf lokal port 5000 das heißt ich muss meine anwendung
nicht irgendwie da global lauschen lassen und ich mich mache einfach die
firewall an erlaubt da nur port 80 und gut ist der restliche kram läuft lokal
host und da kümmert sich dann auch um den um das zertifikats management das ist
angenehmer finde ich und da gibt es tausende varianten wie man das ganze
machen kann von die oldschool leute neben apache man kann engine x nehmen man kann
kaddi nehmen man kann traffic nehmen man kann was auch immer ha proxy oder was
auch sonst wie nehmen also reverse proxies beziehungsweise web server gibt
es massig ja aber ich finde der hier ist ganz gut weil den kann jeder depp auch
konfigurieren das ist genau das richtige für mich in dem fall da muss ich nicht
lange überlegen um den kaddi reverse proxy zu aufzusetzen da ist wirklich
das ist nahezu idiotensicher ja du musst im endeffekt den kram installieren
einmal kurz verschiebt mal kurz das fenster
ups what the console verschoben soll ich nicht so komisches zeug drücken
als champ genau und das ding ist wirklich idiotensicher
das werde ich gleich sehen also so einfach kann man finde ich mit nix reverse
proxy aufsetzen das ist der mit adi mit abstand einfachste
variante wir machen es natürlich so wie was wie man es immer machen sollte
möglichst viele unbekannte kommandos aus dem internet in die shell kopieren
das ist ja ist ja allgemein bekannt dass das der wech ist wie man seine
surfer installiert am besten was was noch besser ist was noch besser ist
karl blablabla.de pipe nach basch also das das ist das ist natürlich noch besser
genau und kann die macht auch letztendlich kripp zertifikate das heißt das ding ist
wirklich absolut top für so einfache kleine installation die haben ja auch ein
schönes getting getting started drinnen using caddy file
sudokolle was recht nie sudokolle bringt nix du musst du musst machen karl pipe
pipe nach sudo basch weil ich glaube nach der pipe gilt das sudo nicht mehr
kann das rechten zentrum an der uni über bbb die was ist was ist bbb fragst
mich da sachen keine ahnung kein schimmer so
getting started die hatten die caddy file da haben wir es doch
ne das ist alles blödsinn brauchen wir alles nicht also ich habe es jetzt installiert etc
caddy file übrigens by the way wenn ihr jetzt auf die seite geht eventuell
ne ich glaube ich glaube jetzt noch nicht aber wenn man auf die ip vom server geht
kommt mal leute ihr könnt jetzt mal auf quatscht bin ja bei mir lokal ihr könnt
jetzt mal hier drauf gehen da müsstet ihr eigentlich eine caddy seite sehen wo drauf
steht it works oder auch nicht das eigentlich vermute das geht schon
ich hätte eigentlich erwartet dass das schon eine seite kommt aber ich ne seite
ach ich habe die firewall angeschaltet alle ich kann nur laud lull muss man sich auch nicht
wundern dass es nicht geht so hier also wenn ihr auf die ip geht müsstet ihr jetzt eigentlich
alle das da schon bekommen kann es sein dass sich irgendwelche
emoji fonts nicht installiert haben was kommt denn da normalerweise
japanische dinger stimmt ich habe keine japanische schriftarten installiert
genau so und der vorteil davon ist jetzt meine dotnet anwendung die muss was für
eine seite ja es ist echt grausam wie schaft die ist oder ich muss meine dotnet anwendung
nicht global am internet lauschen lassen ja so ok jetzt kommentiere ich den ganzen krempel mal
aus und wir führen jetzt unsere eigene config ein also ihr werdet sehen einfacher könnt ihr
kein webserver programmieren kein webserver konfigurieren als als mit caddy man sagt
einfach die domain price jam.org jetzt muss ich mal nachgucken wie man jemanden response macht
response hello world ja so und was mehr braucht man nicht was das macht ist sich ein zertifikat
holen für price jam.org und nicht dass ich jetzt mist erzähle warte mal es kann sein
dass ich jetzt noch mal kurz hatte tps dings gucken muss
ne das war es der holt sich jetzt ein zertifikat im hintergrund und ihr werdet gleich sehen wenn
die video auf die seite geht hat das ding ein gültiges zertifikat einfacher kann es wirklich
nicht gehen was wir jetzt noch machen müssen ist hatte tps erlauben und caddy restarten
oder reloaden so und jetzt gehen wir mal price jam.org moment beta beta price jam.org das hat noch
kein zertifikat warum nicht status warum geht das nicht ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet
dass es direkt geht falsche domain ach ich depp jaja falsche domain lulw ok nochmal ja
wenn man nicht aufpasst ne wie ging das noch journal journal ctl xe ne ach was auch immer
mal gucken ob es jetzt funktioniert post jam da sind wir und wir haben ein gültiges zertifikat
also einfacher kann es ja nicht sein wieso lässt du deinen tracker nicht auf dem raspberry
pie laufen weil dann keiner drauf zugreifen kann außer ich selbst
das zertifikat kommt direkt von netz encrypt und wird auch automatisch alle was ich das
60 90 tage oder was auch immer erneuert also einfacher kannst du es wirklich nicht machen
also mehr geht nicht mehr geht echt nicht zertifikate das funktioniert natürlich nur
wenn ihr andere sachen machen wollt müsst ihr dns challenge machen da könnt ihr auch
alles mögliche machen aber jungs jetzt sagt doch mal ob der kack verfolgbar ist und nicht
hä was wie wo chat um was gehts überhaupt was ist wie wo verfolgbar ich hab chat vergessen
aufzumachen der panther 1402 hat irgendwelche dinger angestellt
was hat er dann angestellt ich finde es gar nicht
was ich will jemand anzeigen aber das ist aber nicht so gut ich habe ich verstehe nicht
um was es geht er hat seinen dozenten beleidigt naja je nachdem was du gesagt hast ist das
sicherlich straf nicht ohne aber für die meisten sachen sollte dir wahrscheinlich
nichts passieren warum hast du das vor allem unter einem
echten namen gemacht ich glaube nicht dass dir irgendwas passiert
je nachdem was sie davon sich gegeben hat also wirklich verstanden habe ich es nicht
wenn die irgendwie sagen dass in die sagen man soll sich freiwillig melden wer es war
ne das sagen die nur weil die keine ahnung haben wer es ist
das rechenzentrum kann das eher nicht nachverfolgen es sei denn du bist im irgendwie im im studenten
wohnheim oder sonst wo und du kriegst irgendwie deine ip von da und die haben locks und sonst
was und dann ist fragwürdig ob sie das überhaupt haben dürfen
ich der gut dafür kenne ich die technik ehrlich gesagt zu wenig aber das klingt mir jetzt
erstmal nicht so als geht das
aber zugeben würde ich prinzipiell nix also wenn die nicht genau wissen was sache ist
dann würde ich mich nicht hinstellen oder ich war es das ist ja im prinzip
und im zweifelsfall und im zweifelsfall kannst du einfach sagen es haben noch mehr leute
zugang zu deinem rechner gehabt und spätestens dann kann es die keiner mehr schräg draus
drehen dass du das warst wenn du mehr leute im haushalt hast die zugang zum rechner haben
kann es jeder gewesen sein was wiederum auf der anderen seite wenn du wirklich illegale
dinge anstellt scheiße ist weil dann bist du als anschlussinhaber in der regel dran
solltest du aufpassen aber in dem fall nee never da passiert nix
also wie gesagt ich kenne die technik nicht panther 1402 ich habe keinen blassen schimmer
davon aber es klingt mir nicht sehr praktikabel dass man dich da irgendwie nachverfolgen
kann genau das ist wie wenn irgendwie einer sagt sie wissen doch sicher was sie falsch
gemacht haben da wird der wird der muss dir das erzählen
ok also weiter geht's betah preis camp orc ist am start seht ihr mal wir haben mit ein
bisschen konfig mit ein bisschen konfig gültiges zertifikat und eine response auf der seite
jetzt müssen wir noch den reverse proxy einstellen dass die dotnet anwendung funktioniert und
dann
seid ist mega lahm chat seid ihr das seid ihr schon auf einem rechner drauf über den
server gibts zu chat ihr seid ihr seid dafür verantwortlich wo mein browser so langsam
ist
ich kenne euch chat so reverse proxy hier das da brauchen wir so und alles was wir machen
müssen dass die dotnet anwendung funktioniert ist dem zu sagen er soll proxen auf local
horse local horse genau local horse port 5000 easy fertig das war es jetzt müssen wir noch
die dotnet anwendung da draufschieben und starten und dann seht ihr den preis camp auf
preis camp auf betah.preiscamp.org und danach müssen wir noch dafür sorgen dass das tracking
auch funktioniert
der chat wieder netcat-l ohja unbedingt da ist die hacker mans an start guck mal hier
port 80 ist sogar auf monkaS eigentlich können wir port 80 wieder zu machen aber port 80
ist insofern ganz praktisch weil der redirect machen kann kann der kann jetzt muss ich mal
ausbilden kann der redirecten preiscamp.org beta wo bin ich eigentlich so dumm und vergesse
beta immer guck mal der kann redirecten excellent excellent
sollen wir die delos protection überprüfen zuhause verschalte ich den server einfach ab
dann ist genug delos protection ok leute also jetzt muss ich erstmal die dotnet anwendung
da draufschieben der preiscamp
ja preiscamp geht aus
also es gibt jetzt zwei varianten wenn man die dotnet anwendung auf den server laufen
lassen will entweder man ist super agile und klont sein git repo da drauf und macht dort
den buildprozess panther wir sind hier keine irgendwie rechtsberatung noch kennen wir
uns damit aus ich glaube aber nicht dass du dir so viel gedanken zu machen musst dass
dir überhaupt irgendwas passiert ist mal andere frage was hast du oder nicht nicht ich frage
anders nicht was hast du gesagt was wurde denn in diesem dokument wie wurde denn der
dozent beleidigt was wurde ihm denn an kopf geschmissen sag mal das interessiert mich
jetzt
also irgendjemand hat in diesem dokument ja was geschrieben du warst ja natürlich nicht
ähm was haben die denn geschrieben was haben die denn geschrieben sag mal
mich interessiert jetzt mich interessiert jetzt echt was so was so was so schlimmes
ist ich meine es wird ja über es wird ja darüber rausgehen dass es ein depp ist oder
so oder ihr werdet wahrscheinlich ein bisschen ein bisschen mehr erzählt haben oder ja genau
ich weiß du warst ja nicht aber sag mal was was was was was wie wurde denn der dozent
beleidigt ich will es jetzt genau wissen also wenn ihr wenn ihr gesagt habt es ist ein
spinner oder so ich glaube nicht dass dir da irgendwie auch eine ansatzweise was passieren
kann aber ich will jetzt will ich wissen jetzt will ich wissen also über was für eine sorte
von beleidigung reden wir hier denn habt ihr die mutter gefickt oder was irgendwas in
der richtung muss es doch gewesen sein sagt er nichts mehr hab ich gesagt ja gut also
wie gesagt ich glaube nicht dass man das raus rausfinden kann oder geschweige denn dir das
irgendwie nachweisen und im zweifelsfall wenn in deinem haushalt mehrere leute zugang zu
deinem rechner haben wird es eh schwierig das dir das in die schuhe zu schieben aber
ganz ehrlich ich würde einfach die füße stillhalten und nicht unnötig auf mich aufmerksam
machen ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben leute ich hab voll voll vergessen preischen bis
am start genau also das ist die dotnet anwendung die wollen wir jetzt auf den server drauf
schieben und laufen lassen es gibt zwei varianten wie man was man machen kann mit einer dotnet
anwendung man kann die einmal self content bauen dann enthält das alles was es braucht
um die dotnet anwendung zum laufen zu bekommen auf dem server oder man kann sie quasi source
mäßig hinschieben und dort dotnet installieren und dann da starten ich würde sagen wir machen
man self content build ist einfacher hack wait was ah falsch ich mach mal kurz ich mach
mal kurz ein update haben die eigentlich mittlerweile schon dotnet 5 in den normalen paketquellen
drin oder immer noch nicht haben die mittlerweile dotnet 5 drinnen immer noch nicht langweilig
langweilig ok jetzt haben wir eine self content dotnet anwendung die können wir jetzt auf
der anderen seite starten soweit in der theorie das kopieren wir den jetzt kopieren wir die
anwendung auf den server drauf also scp-r gute frage nächste frage ip wobei ich brauch
die ip gar nicht ich kann einfach beta.preischen.org verwenden warum hat mich eigentlich noch keiner
gefragt warum ne.org domain die anderen waren vergeben ne ich hab ne.org domain genommen
erst mal die billig war weil es irgendwie vertrauenswürdig aussieht und weil es erstmal
kostenlos ist was das erst mal weil es immer kostenlos ist erstmal ist bescheuert ich werde
dafür garantiert nie irgendwie dass so services kannst du nicht kostenpflichtig anbieten
dann benutzt dich keiner immer kostenlos das einzige was ich vielleicht mache ist Amazon
reflink rein oder so so cd publish und da ist meine dotnet anwendung wow noch mehr please
price champ was was no such file or directory hä da ist es doch
hä ok das ist da fehlt irgendeine dotnet abhängigkeit hä wtf das ist irgendeine dotnet bug garantiert
self content does not work ja so siehts aus jetzt ist ich brauch kein ca mod-x das ding
ist da und es hat auch execute rechte da ist irgendwas anderes kaputt guck mal hier der
als gleiche 8 ist schon installiert ok dann hab ich ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung was das
für schmerzen hat hä ich kann den kram für meinen raspberry pi bilden hinkopieren ausführen
und es geht warum hat es mit dem x6 ähm warum hat es mit 64 spit ubuntu probleme hä file
was nicht installiert mal mit bash versuchen das ist ne bash das liegt nicht an der shell
oder sonst was das liegt an diesem dotnet ding oh was denn das ich glaub dotnet über
snap hat da wieder irgendwie komische dinger gemacht das ist ne gute Idee das können wir
probieren aber eigentlich sollte es nichts äh ja bla bla da ist da ist irgendwas da
ist irgendwas im bild kaputt gegangen ne dotnet price jam nicht das ist ne self content anwendung
ich hab kein dotnet drauf ich kann dotnet installieren aber weil die self content ich
kann dotnet installieren aber warum geht das nicht das liegt garantiert das liegt garantiert
an diesem kack über snap installierten könnte ich wetten könnte ich wetten wir können einfach
dotnet installieren und gut ist schatt eh nix ah restart firefox ok snap ist übelster
crap hä ich hätte es anders ins anderweitig installieren sollen ubuntu install dotnet
die haben mittlerweile glaub sogar offizielle repos ne plan 9 jetzt wirds ja immer abgedreht
da hier da das brauchen wir auf ne moment äh 2004 erstmal wieder paar sachen copy pasten
aus dem internet in die shell mit sudo davor genau so macht man es leute so und jetzt installieren
snap ist totaler crap aber es ist eh nicht schlecht wenn wir dotnet drauf installiert
haben dann kann ich den kram später da auch drauf bilden und sonst was wobei ich ganz
ehrlich das bild will ich eigentlich über github actions machen ist viel einfacher
warum kam eigentlich snap überhaupt drauf ne snap ist nicht drauf ich hab lokal dotnet
über snap installiert und ich glaub dass da dran liegt dass der irgendwie was verkackt
hat so ok also wenn wir glück haben dann kann ich das jetzt einfach starten und ihr
seht direkt den den preis champ what the fuck ach die dl muss man starten genau da ist
der preis champ localhost alles klar beta.preischamp.org da ist er leute habt ihr auch den preis champ
nice
Okay, ist der gut?
Exzellent.
Gut, und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich noch das wichtigste, weil jetzt müssen wir dafür
sorgen, dass der Tracker funktioniert.
Der Tracker geht ja noch gar nicht.
Also aktuell trackt der ja gar nichts, deswegen mach ich jetzt noch mal aus, mach mal TMAX
auf,.NET, Run, ViceChamp, DLL, so und da unten machen wir jetzt den Tracker drauf,
dass es auch funktioniert.
So und dann machen wir, dann gucken wir was wir für Shops rein machen.
Übrigens, wir machen das natürlich alles unter Route, wir wollen ja, dass das möglichst
sicher ist.
Was sonst, warum nicht.org, ne die war übelst billig, ich bezahle glaube ich 5.30 oder so
im Jahr.
Achso, Moment, hab ich überhaupt Node installiert?
Hab ich überhaupt Node installiert, Node, ah ne, Abt, Info, Node.js oder was, Yam Info,
ich komm immer durcheinander.
Was für ne Version ist das?
Was für ne Node Version 10, ob das geht, Abt, Install, Node.js, so was braucht man,
Node installieren, NPM und dann NPMi, NPM Run Start, davor müssen wir die Konfig noch
anpassen.
Ich find's immer noch geil, dass man mittlerweile Node installieren kann, MonkaS, Alter jetzt
wird erstmal das halbe Internet installiert, jetzt vorbei, aber Node selber läuft, oder?
Ok, wir installieren das halbe Internet, was solls, YOLO, aber man braucht Node, oh man
braucht Node 14, ok, dann müssen wir vielleicht Node 14 noch installieren, oder wir lassen
es im Docker-Container laufen, das könnt man auch machen, aber ich will für so ein
Ding jetzt eigentlich noch Docker installieren, dann hast du wieder das Problem, dass die
Ubuntu Firewall nicht richtig funktioniert, weil wenn Docker am Start ist, so ist man
eigentlich lieber, ok, also halbe Internet ist drauf, wie viel Speicherplatz haben wir
eigentlich, wir haben 20G, ah, reicht, packst du das auch auf GitHub, vielleicht, ja, reicht
nicht genau, NPM, NPMi, mal gucken, vielleicht gehts auch mit Node 10, wenn ich jetzt die
Node Modules installiert hab, ist erstmal Festplatte voll, kannst du mal richtig vorstellen,
ok, es scheint schon mal zu laufen, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert, mit Node 10, Node ist
ein JavaScript, ist ein JavaScript-Rantreiben für den Server, das ist eigentlich eines
der bekanntesten Dinger auf der Welt, die es gibt mittlerweile, Node.js, weil die ganzen
Hipster, ganzen Hipster-Frontend-Leute jetzt Server-Dinger bauen können damit, freuen
sie sich, download Chrome, hack wait, gut, ich meine, es ist klar, warum der Chrome runterladet,
der lädt Chrome runter, damit er die Websites passen kann, bzw. die Websites abrufen kann
und besser Browser faken kann, ok, Rans Start, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert, Postchamp,
Postchamp, Postchamp, läuft es denn, aha, oh, was des, lib, aha, da fehlt was, da fehlt
was, da muss ich irgendwas installieren, ab, install, lib, nss, drei, drei, jawoll, einfach
mal random dependencies installieren, bis es funktioniert, easy, so, jetzt auf, du musst
es nicht nochmal kompilieren, einfach starten, du hast das schon mal kompiliert, aber es
hat NPM wahrscheinlich gecheckt, da sind wir, easy, oh, lib, aha, ok, Moment, was muss ich
als Abhängigkeit installieren, haben die das hier irgendwie draufstehen, dependencies,
abinstall, wisst ihr was, ich könnte jetzt Trick 17 machen, einfach abinstall Chrome
sagen, und dann installiert er ja alle Abhängigkeiten, die mir für Chrome braucht, hoffe ich, Snap,
abbrechen, abbrechen, ich will kein Snap, der installiert es als Snap mittlerweile,
ah, schrecklich, ich muss es jetzt fertig installieren, weil ich hab zwischendrin abgebrochen,
jetzt kackt er ab, warum denn als Snap, was ist mit euch los, die Ubuntu Leute, ja, dafür
wird Ubuntu doch voll kritisiert, weil sie Chrome heimlich als Snap installieren, hab
ich noch nie mitgekriegt, weil ich verwende Ubuntu auf dem Desktop nicht, und auf dem
Server installiert, der bringt kein Chrome, aber was ist das hier für ein Kack, erst begleiche
ich, ich will gleich wieder deinstallieren danach, alles weg, Ruby, das habt ihr euch
gemerkt, was macht der da eigentlich im Hintergrund gerade, ich breche das oben mal ab, was macht
der da eigentlich gerade, ah Snap install Chrome, toll, super, war eine gute Idee Chrome
zu installieren, ich hätte einfach die lib installieren sollen und gut ist, ok wunderbar,
kann ich das jetzt auch wieder deinstallieren, und der deinstalliert wirklich alles, inklusive
Snap, das natürlich noch drauf, also auto-remove, der installiert den Kack einfach und löscht
danach nicht mehr, alter Ubuntu Leute, normalerweise hätte ich erwartet, dass der nachdem ich
desinstalliert hab, was es installiert hat, warum muss ich das von Hand machen, warum
ist das Ding so doof und checkt es nicht automatisch, dass es das als Abhängigkeit installiert hat,
ja klar kann ich das von Hand deinstallieren, aber es sackt doch, was ich das von Hand deinstallieren
muss, was genau ist oder macht Snap, Snap ist ein Frontend für Container, für Linus-Container,
das ist ein bisschen so was wie Docker, nur Ubuntu Style Docker, aber es ist Müll, kannst
du dir ja merken, das reicht, das ist genug, ok dann installieren wir die lib jetzt, so
snap install, was lib, rtk, ok, ne lib, lib, rtk, welche denn jetzt, 1, 1.0, 1.0.0,
geil dass die Libraries so tolle Namen haben, weiß man gleich Bescheid, so läufts jetzt,
wir gucken mal auf dem GitHub bei dem, ob der irgendwo ne Dependency Liste hat, ach guck
mal wiki, wiki, ja da stehts doch, installation dem hier, ah vielleicht hätte ich mal, vielleicht
hätte ich mal in das wiki gucken sollen, dann gehts auch einfach, Docker ist nice,
Snap ist Müll, ja ich sollte das ganze, ich hätte das ganze Ding im Docker laufen lassen
sollen, aber ich will auf der Kiste kein Docker drauf haben, da geht die Firewall nicht richtig,
man muss doch irgendwelche special Sachen machen, Tokulesen 2020, ja wer macht denn
sowas auch schon, so jetzt aber, jetzt startet es hoffentlich, Postchamp Leute, Gift im
Energy, ja und, ach leck mich, was ist das Problem, was hat der denn jetzt für Schmerzen
hier, ach so weil ich das als Route laufen lasse, ok dann lass ichs eben nicht als Route
laufen, ok ich lass es nicht als Route laufen, dann lösche ichs wieder, da, da machen wir
neuen User, ich kann mir immer nicht merken, ob es Add User oder User Add ist, was ist
das mit dem Skript, Add User oder User Add, wer hat das auch so genannt, was doch Add
User, warum, warum gibt es da zwei verschiedene Dinger, ich kann mir immer nicht merken was
es ist, Add User, User Add, Add User ist das Richtige, dann ist die Manpage aber auch fail,
ach komm, was auch immer, Add User, Tja, Poggers, Passwort, ich geb dir mal ein gescheites Passwort,
weil ich bin nicht sicher bin, ob da standardmäßig SSH Login hat, ich schalte eh alle SSH Login
hab, man kann auch einfach ein Ausrufezeichen in die Passwörter in die Shadow machen, ok,
ist das Information korrekt, yes, ETC, SSHD, ne SSH, SSHD und jetzt deaktivieren wir einfach,
das ist das, was ich letztes Mal auch gesagt hab, was man machen soll, jetzt deaktivieren
wir einfach, Permit Root Login, Moment, Mist, ich bin mir gerade gar nicht mehr sicher, was
das war, wie kommt man Passwort Authentifizierung, Passwort, Passwort Authentification, no, ich
glaub das wars, ne, ich glaub mehr muss man nicht machen, ich bin aus dem Kopf gar nicht
mehr so sicher, ist das SSHD, SSH, ok, alles klar, dann hat sich's erledigt, so ok, also
so weiter haben wir's, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben, ich mein wir können auch noch
das ausschalten mit, ich glaub, Minus L oder so, genau, man kann glaube ich mal PassWD,
Minus L, Poggers, oder, war das Minus L, Log Password of Name, ja genau, so, also dann
werden wir jetzt mal User Poggers und machen das ganze noch mal, weil Chrome möchte ja
nicht unter Root laufen, was ich irgendwie auch nachvollziehen kann, Git, Clone, Sack,
ist der neue User berechtigt SSH zu nutzen, wahrscheinlich ist das standardmäßig, aber
jetzt mit Login ist eh vorbei, NPMI, und was muss man dann machen, einfach Start, ne, ach
ne, das stand bei dem auf der, genau, so, jetzt hoffen wir mal, dass es jetzt funktioniert,
zu Trackhorn, jetzt haben wir schon Fail, wenn du Sachen nicht öfters machst, ja, vergisst
das total schnell, so, Chrome wird downgeloadet, alles gut, jetzt sind wir User Poggers, da
kann ja nichts mehr schiefgehen, erstmal das halbe Internet downloaden, so muss das sein,
ja, also klar, wir donaten mal nebenbei noch an alle Projekte, die wir runterladen, natürlich,
was sonst, wenn das jetzt nicht geht, habe ich echt ein Problem, weil ich bin darauf
angewiesen, dass das Teil läuft, weil das ist das, was das eigentliche Abrufen der Verfügbarkeitsinformation
macht.
Mein Webfrontend ist schön und gut, ich starte es mal wieder, dass ihr es euch angucken
könnt, den Preischamp, aber, ah, das sieht besser aus, das sieht besser aus, der Unterschied
zwischen su-poggers und su-poggers ist, dass su- noch Loginskrips ausführt, ah, ok, jetzt
funktioniert es, exzellent, ok, sehr gut, wunderbar, so, und was wir jetzt machen müssen,
jetzt müssen wir das Ding konfigurieren, weil aktuell fragt es nur Best Buy und Amazon
ab, das ist natürlich nicht so Sinn und Zweck der Sache, das heißt, wir werden, achso, das
ist Local House, ne, ne, wir werden den Preischamp, den Preischamp, der wird nie was sinnvolles
anzeigen.
Ok, weg damit, also, mv.net, ne, nicht.net, net, ne, dot, dot, enf, genau, enf, so, jetzt
können wir den Kram editieren, was wir haben wollen, und zwar, also, jetzt muss ich mal
kurz überlegen, was man da alles einstellen muss, dass es funktioniert, also ASCII-Banner
wollen wir auf jeden Fall haben, dass es cooler aussieht, natürlich mit color, was sonst,
versteht sich von selbst, Auto add to cart, das brauchen wir alles nicht, wir verwenden
ja nur das tracken, country.de brauchen wir auch nicht, webport brauchen wir auch alles
nicht, es gab da irgendwie store, hier, stores, genau, da muss man jetzt eintragen, was man
für stores verwenden will, supported stores, also, was nehmen wir denn, welche rolle spielt
.net, mein, hier, das da ist eine ASP.net Anwendung, das Webinterface dazu, den preistracker,
also den street merchant verwende ich nur zum preise scrapen, crawlen, was auch immer,
und dann meine Anwendung bescheid sagen, wenn was verfügbar ist, meine Anwendung nimmt das,
schreibt es lokal, basier ich in SQLite Datenbank, und man kann den Webinterface drauf, und vor
allem kriege ich eine coole preishistory dann, also was für stores nehmen wir denn jetzt
mal, was gibt es denn hier, amazon, also amazon, amazon.de brauchen wir auf jeden Fall schon
mal, Hando gibt es da, glaube ich, net, oder, gibt es das da, stores, also alternate, alternate,
Amazon haben wir, AMD, AMD direkt, klar, wobei 360ti, ja geil, das kann auch CPUs und so,
dann checkt mal ruhig mal auf AMD, ob eine Nvidia Karte verfügbar ist, alles klar, direkt
bei Asus, ist sicherlich auch nicht verkehrt, Asus, ähm, kann man einfach country.de machen
und er checkt alles, nicht das, kann ich sagen country.de und er checkt alles, das wäre natürlich
POG, ich will filtern, ich will filtern auf, ich will filtern auf, äh, 3060ti, irgendwie
show, show, ah hier, 3060ti, massive traffic, ja, Vinuxshop 20TB, ok, guck mal, guck mal
jetzt mal, ob der einfach jetzt alle deutschen Shops macht, wenn man de reinschreibt, dann,
dann müsste ich das nicht von Hand reinschreiben und einfach alles checken lassen, easy, easy
as fuck, achso, Moment, ich hab das wichtigste vergessen, lull, die Kommunikation zwischen
meiner Anwendung und dem Street Merchant hab ich vergessen und zwar, ich hab das folgendermaßen
gemacht, ich hatte die Auswahl, ich machs über Redis oder ich machs über MQTT und ich machs
über MQTT, ich hab in meiner.net Anwendung einen ganz simplen MQTT Broker und der kriegt
einfach eine Nachricht geschickt, sobald was verfügbar ist und dann zeigt das das Webinterface
an, wie gesagt, das Webinterface hab ich, ich hab das ganze Ding heute gebaut in dreieinhalb
Stunden, ich hab wirklich nur das Minimalste reingemacht, was irgendwie funktioniert, dass
es irgendwie funktioniert, ja, wir werden auch gleich testen, ob es funktioniert, ich
schick einfach mal eine Fake MQTT Message ab, oder vielleicht hat der ja zufällig irgendeinen
Shop auch was, was zur Verfügung, irgendeine Fake MQTT Message ab, um zu gucken, ob es funktioniert,
Test, warum nur, das kann alles, das kann alles, das ist ja das Gute da dran, Gab doch
eben so ein Testcode, Test, Test Notification, konnte man machen, NPM, ne, äh, was, so, hier
hat man den Kram nochmal getestet, ne, ich bin ja zu dumm für NPM Run, ja, was kippt
das Kram, aber ich hab das jetzt richtig gemacht, Help, General, Test, Reference, Notification,
Test, ah, NPM Run, Test Notification, ok, das hab ich mir richtig zusammen gereimt,
ah, guck mal, er hat's erkannt, hier, Message, Test Name, Test Brand, ok, easy, er hat's
erkannt, dass es am Start ist, ok, nice, übrigens, mir fällt grad auf, ich hab noch was vergessen
und zwar, dass das Ganze funktioniert, das hab ich jetzt, hab ich jetzt, hab ich jetzt,
äh, gar nicht dran gedacht, ich musste eine Sache patchen an diesem Street Merchant und
zwar, dass der mir alle Informationen in diese MQTT Message schickt, das macht er standardmäßig
nicht, so, und da musste ich zwei Zeilen oder so ändern, mal gucken, ob ich das jetzt auf
die Reihe kriege, Notification, genau, hier wo er die Message zusammen baut, der gibt
nämlich nur den Link und den Store, also sprich, der schreibt hier nur Name und Brand
von der Grafikkarte hin und ob's in Stock ist und die Uhrl, das bringt mir nix, ich will
ja auch Preis wissen und alle möglichen Sachen, deswegen muss ich das ein bisschen umschreiben,
ähm, und, ah doch, ich hab's mir kopiert, poggers nice, excellent, zwar muss ich das
hier löschen, das hab ich im Vorfall schon ausprobiert, muss ich das hier löschen, darf
ich das da reinschreiben, wow, exquisite formatiert, alles klar, so, so ist besser, jetzt schreibt
er mir nämlich alle Sachen rein, inklusive Preis, er schreibt den Namen vom Store und
er schreibt sogar noch ein Datum dabei, wann er das verschickt hat, so, run, schauen wir
mal, ob das jetzt funktioniert, oh nee, Moment, ich muss jetzt starten oben, Preischamp, Preischamp
starte mal schnell, auf, gib alles Preischamp, das ist schneller gestartet, bis dann unten,
der Preischamp ist langsam, not even testing, ich, oh, ich hab was kaputt gemacht, was hab
ich vergessen, was hab ich, ah, String, nee wie schreibt man das, Stringify, so, dass
er Text draus macht, ok, ich hoffe jetzt hab ich's richtig gemacht, jetzt hätt ich mir
eigentlich aufschreiben müssen, das ist das einzige was ich daran patchen muss, dass
es funktioniert und jetzt sagt er mir alles mögliche zu diesem Produkt was verfügbar
ist, Preis, Shop, Url, Typ, Serie, Hersteller, genau, guckt, jetzt sagt er mir Brand, da
steht dann so was wie AMD oder Asus oder so drinne, die Url zum Einkaufswagen, die Url
zur Shopseite, ein Datum dabei, Name vom Shop, Model, also 3060ti oder sowas in der
Richtung, ja, das ist dann nice, so, jetzt würd ich sagen dann starten wir das mal jetzt,
Run, nee Run, Start muss man machen, ne, Uhrzeit stimmt nicht, doch Uhrzeit stimmt,
aber der Server ist, hat andere Zeitzone, so, jetzt gucken wir mal ob der Eintrag.de gereicht
hat, dass der alles, nee der macht immer nur noch AmazUnknownCountry.de, Moment, warum
ist CountryUnknown, SupportedCountry, ach da muss jetzt Germany reinschreiben, ah ok,
Moment, ich muss doch die Shops von Hand reinschreiben, ok, nice, top, top, sehr durchsichtig
das ganze, sehr durchsichtig, Shops, ok SupportedStores, also dann machen wir das ganze doch nochmal
von Hand, Ups, also, Store, ok Country machen wir mal wieder weg, das war ja egal, Store,
also Amazon.de, Alternate.de, Asus.de, AMD.de, da sind wir stehen geblieben, so, AntOnline
kenn ich nicht, was ist denn alles, Arlt, Arlt kommt da auch noch rein, alles wird alles
durchgecrawled, Asus.de haben wir, CaseKing, der Auer muss auch am Start sein, dann haben
wir ComputerUniverse, noch die Cyberport, das ist irgendein ostdeutscher Laden, das
weiß ich noch, da hat der MasterCrabber mir früher erzählt, bestell der immer, so, Euronics,
also wird alles gecrawled, easy, ich, Moment, was für ein Ding, die Seite habe ich schon
nie gehört, Equipper, ok, Expert, jawoll, easy, easy, alles rein, Futurex, was für,
was ist das alles, habe ich alles noch nie gehört, GameStop, 0W, MediaMarkt, vielleicht
soll ich doch nicht alles rein machen, das erzeugt vielleicht ein bisschen viel Traffic,
MindFactory, ok, ich mache erstmal alles rein, dann kopiere ich das und wir schmeißen
wieder ein paar Sachen raus, die eh kein Mensch bestellt, Overclockers, da habe ich im Moment,
ne, was ist das für ein Shop, Moment, das ist UK, ich habe mich verguckt, Otto, deutscher
OttoLan ist am Start, nice, PCKing, war PCKing nicht Scam, oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander,
irgendeiner dieser Shops war doch mal bekannt dafür, dass die, ne, PCKing war das nicht,
oder, ah, PC Fritz, genau, PC Fritz, du hast recht, PC Fritz war das, ich habe es jetzt
durcheinander gebrannt, weil die gibt es doch gar nicht mehr, Spielegrotte, beste Seite,
da habe ich früher mit dem Fabian immer die ganzen Xbox Games bestellt, die Seite sieht
immer noch so aus, wie vor 10 Jahren, ok, das wars, ok, es sind vielleicht ein bisschen
viele Stores, aber wir gucken mal, wir probieren es mal aus, die filtern ja nur auf 3060 Ti,
auch der Preischamp, bam, also jetzt, jetzt wird alles gefiltert, mal gucken, ob es irgendwo
verfügbar ist, vielleicht ist ja sogar irgendwo verfügbar, Cloudflare Waiting, na gut, das
kann manchmal schon vorkommen, die erkennen, dass sie gecrawled werden, Equipper, Leute,
Equipper ist out of stock, kurz gucken, wie viel Traffic das verursacht, also CPU juckt
nicht wirklich, oh, CPU ist 100%, ich muss ihm glaube ich sagen, der darf nicht so viel
parallelisieren, oh, der checkt glaube ich gerade irgendwie 50 Milliarden Dinger parallel,
das ist keine so gute Sache, das müssen wir irgendwie beschränken, was der parallel macht,
ich habe nur ein Core, ja, komm, wir upgraden das Teil jetzt mal schnell, Hetzner, konnte
man jetzt nicht on the fly sogar upgraden, oder wie ging das, man konnte es, man konnte
es on the fly upgraden, glaube ich, wo ist das denn, Rescale, genau, ach komm, CPU, 3,
ja, komm, 8 Monat, easy geht, kann man danach auch wieder downcranen, andere, das wird ein
bisschen teuer, komm, 3, 3 Cores ist gut, oder fährt er das jetzt noch runter, ah,
Server sieht es zu power down, genau, ach guck mal, ach nee, das war das Test, ja, der Preischamp,
tja, ok, da mache ich mal aus, der Websocket Endpoint steht noch auf Flowclosed,
ups, ups, ja, das ist doch ok, nee, das ist nicht ok, fürs Frontend ist das nicht ok,
ja, das, dann geht es nicht, dann ist es kaputt, wartet mal, oh, ups, ok, Max, please fix, wo
sind wir denn hier, Preischamp, liegt, ok, der Preischamp, der Preischamp muss mal kurz
ausgeschaltet werden, Preischamp, ah, wir machen es hier mal auf, kurz, Moment, nee,
Quatsch, ich muss nicht mit Rider aufmachen, das ist ja nur Frontend, das ist ja nur Frontend,
naja, genau, Source, wo hatten sie das jetzt versteckt, ja, hier, ja, ich habe natürlich
die Abfragen rausgeschmissen, komm, ich schreibe jetzt da, warte, ich schreibe jetzt da Hardcoded,
die IP rein und gut ist, aber mein Port 5000 stimmt ja dann auch nicht, Port 80 ist es
dann, oh, ich habe noch was drin, ha, null, hat glaube ich noch keiner, ach, Moment, 80,
wie direktet ja gar, warte mal, jetzt muss ich mal überlegen, wie machen wir das denn
jetzt, warte mal, jetzt muss ich mal kurz überlegen, der soll, warte mal, der ist Lokal,
Port 5000, aber das müsste jetzt eigentlich, ach nee, Quatsch, das funktioniert natürlich
nicht, weil der da nicht proxied auf dem Ding, Beta, PriceChamp, GraphQR, ah, ist das jetzt?
Wie konnte man nochmal Websocket testen, wie SCAT oder sowas, Websocket Testtool, was gab
es denn da, SCAT, ja mein wegen, stimmt, wie machen wir jetzt den Endpoint, also das geht
so schon mal nicht, das hier ist am wahrscheinlichsten, dass es funktioniert, wie connectet man sich
da, Minus C, Unexpected Response, äh, ok, wie kriege ich den jetzt, wie kriege ich den
jetzt dazu, dass der mein, ein Websocket Shit weiterleitet, hm, hatte ich doch, ok, wen kriege
ich den jetzt dazu, dass der mein, ein Websocket Kramproxy, das, eigentlich hätte ich jetzt
erwartet, dass das jetzt so funktioniert, um ehrlich zu sein, ach nee, hier, ja, das
ist richtig, aber, äh, das muss funktionieren, Caddy macht was, der Tracker macht, der Tracker
macht, äh, achso, das läuft gerade gar nicht, äh, der zeigt ja noch, ob eine 360Ti verfügbar
ist, Moment, läuft, läuft der Preischamp gerade nicht, kann das sein, ah, der Preischamp
läuft nicht, da kann es ja auch nicht funktionieren, da ist der Preischamp, RefQR, ah, jetzt funktioniert
es, gut, die Debug-Seite sollte ich vielleicht noch ausschalten, die ist nicht so sinnvoll,
drinnen zu lassen, erste mal, ähm, ich müsste das Ding, ich müsste das Ding, Moment, ich
starte das hier auch falsch, ich will es ja auch als Release starten, sack, natürlich,
habe ich das falsch, falsch gebildet, so, gerade einmal überlegen, wie mache ich denn
das jetzt am besten, ich hab doch jetzt, ich hab doch.NET installiert, ich kann das jetzt
einfach da drauf kopieren und gut ist, ich kopiere einfach mal ein Getrepo da jetzt hin
und fertig, kann ich das da auch lokal machen, so, also das müsste jetzt, das müsste jetzt
zumindest stimmen, was ich hier gebastelt hab, nein, ich will nicht das Terminal closen,
sondern das Ding, ich wird hier ein bisschen Zeug zumachen, das wird mir ein bisschen viel,
so, Repos, Preischamp, nicht Reißchamp, Preischamp, ähm, warum, warum funktionieren die.NET Self-Content
Geschichte nicht, Moment, das ist doch schon Release, na gut, SCP, das ist auch aus, jawoll,
Preischamp bin, ähm, was sind, ich bin gerade, ASP.NET Core Environment Variables für, für,
was das für ein Stage ist und sowas, ASP, Environment, ah ja, genau und dann Production
will ich haben, weil das ist der ganze Mist hier, dass die ganze, dass der auch keine
Developer Pages und sowas anzeigt, das glaube ich nicht so tolle, alles sehr gut durchplanen,
Export gleich, das hat mir jetzt einen Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht, weil das Self-Content
Deployment nicht funktioniert, was mich ultra verwirrt, so, Preischamp, so, wo ist der Preischamp,
da ist er wieder, GraphQL, warum geht das immer noch, ich habe jetzt gesagt, es ist,
es ist, Hosting Environment Production, warum ist das da überhaupt noch drin, habe ich
mich, habe ich da Müll programmiert, ich habe bestimmt Müll programmiert Leute, ich
sag's euch, war das auf Prot, dann habe ich, dann habe ich Müll programmiert, zeige euch
auch wo ich Müll programmiert habe, Open, Home, Max, Repos, ich habe das einfach nicht
ins If reingeschrieben, weil ich übelste Kacknoob bin, pass mal auf, das steht einfach
nicht, Startup, ich habe gesagt, ich habe das mal im Mittag in dreieinhalb Stunden hingewurstet,
es kann ja im Endeffekt nichts passieren, so, ah ja, äußerst clever, wie schalte ich
denn den, wie schalte ich denn den Playground aus, Disable Playground, wie schaltet man
den Gramm aus, das ist eine gute Frage, Disable, nein, jetzt ist auch auf GitHub hoch, kann
schon sein, ja, wie schalte ich denn den Scheiß aus, MapCraftQL, das brauche ich ja, sonst
funktioniert der Aufruf nicht, mal kurz schauen, ob jetzt aber zumindest der Connect zu meinem
GraphQL-Fonst, also es läuft gerade gar nicht, ich habe keinen Streamplan, okay, was, Local
Frost immer noch, was, ich bin übelst verwirrt, ich habe nicht gebildet, erstmal wieder halbe
Internet nachinstallieren, also, wie kriege ich diesen Banana Disable, wie kriege ich
diesen Gramm ausgeschaltet, also ich habe jetzt so einen Debug Playground am Start,
den will ich ja in Produktion gar nicht angeschaltet haben, wie kriege ich den aus, wir müssen
uns jeden Tag Scrum im Kreis stellen, dann kriege ich das automatisch raus, wie das funktioniert,
ja, korrekt, so sieht es aus, ja, ich bin jetzt echt überfragt, sehr merkwürdig, kann
man das hier disablen oder so, nö, keine Ahnung, die Namen sind übelst fail, ja, hm,
so, dann schieben wir das jetzt nochmal neu hin, so, ich habe es jetzt gebildet, ich Self-Container,
SCP, wir kopieren das mal hintereinander, dass ich das nicht immer nacheinander machen
muss, also jetzt hatte ich die Frage, wie kann ich das ausschalten, das ist doof, es
kann doch nicht sein, dass das standardmäßig an ist, aber zumindest sollte die Website
jetzt ordentlich funktionieren, nach der Änderung, auf, schieb alles hin, der kopiert echt das
halbe Internet herum, hopp hopp, ok gut, ok, der Preis-Champ ist am Start, alter, was
willst du mit Local-Host, das habe ich doch gerade gelöscht, hä, was ist denn jetzt
los, warum, was will der mit Local-Host, das habe ich doch gerade hier rausgeschmissen,
ja, genau, so sieht es aus, das habe ich doch gerade hier rausgeschmissen, ha, hier,
da ist nichts Local-Host mehr drin, vielleicht, aber das ist bestimmt gecasht noch, wir machen
jetzt mal anonym auf, der will sich zu, warum willst du dich zu Local-Host verbinden, hä,
der soll sich gefälligst, der soll sich gefälligst zu, hier steht doch mit Local-Host überhaupt
nichts drinne, der soll sich gefälligst verbinden zu beta-preis-champ.org, Moment, ich starte
das mal lokal und gucke, ob es jetzt überhaupt funktioniert, so, ich hab's jetzt, ich bilde
das jetzt, hab ich das oben schon mal gemacht, hab ich das oben schon mal gebildet davor,
ha, nee, ich hab das nur installiert, ich hab's nicht gebildet, ha, ich bin ja auch
doof, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert's, jetzt, so, was ich immer noch nicht gecheckt
hab, wie ich diesen Playground wegkrieg, das ist ja total beknackt, so, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt wird's aber funktionieren mit dem, ups, oh, oh, ganz schlechte Idee, ganz schlechte
Idee, das zu kopieren, während ich das andere noch gestartet hab, das müssen wir noch mal
machen, ha, trotzdem komisch, okay, aber jetzt in der Zwischenzeit kann ich mal gucken,
wie krieg ich diesen Playground, play, Playground, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das total
beknackt wird, das kann doch nicht sein, dass das total beknackt wird, das kann doch nicht
sein, kann man das da oben vielleicht ausschalten, nee, okay, das ist mir zu hoch, dass der Playground
noch an ist, gut, das ist jetzt erstmal nicht so wild, aber das verwirrt mich trotzdem,
so, jetzt mal gucken, ob das mit localhost wenigstens gefixt ist, weiß, okay, das mit
localhost ist jetzt wenigstens gefixt, das heißt, die Websocketverbindung funktioniert
wenigstens richtig, aber das geht halt immer noch, ne, jetzt könnt ihr alle auf diesen
tollen Debugendpunkt gehen, läuft eh bei euch lokal im Browser, aber, so kann man's disablen,
exellent, guck mal, der Chat ist wieder, kommst du bei Default am Apps, Banana Cakepop, können
die ihr Kram auch mal ordentlich nennen, Tool Enable, meine Güte, da wäre ich ja im Leben,
da wäre ich ja im Leben nicht drauf gekommen, was zum Teufel soll das denn sein, okay, also,
tab craftql with options, ne, nicht with options, und dann new options, Paintschamp, Tool, was,
okay, alles klar, alles klar, jetzt, oh, alles klar, jetzt ist es vorbei, True,
Light, False, ja, hey Chat, da ich in letzter Zeit eh nicht mal wirklich viel zocke, möchte
ich mal Linux als mein Main OS verwenden, welches OS würdet ihr empfehlen, kommt drauf an, ja,
genau, Manjaro Mint kann man verwenden, Manjaro ist eher so ein bisschen, wenn man sich schon
damit auskennt, aber wenn man sich tiefer damit beschäftigen will, aber du solltest
dich vorher fragen, ob das wirklich eine gute Idee ist, falls du Windows Software verwendest,
man kriegt einige Sachen unter Linux zum Laufen, aber mehr schlecht als recht, also wenn du
so Sachen wie Photoshop und so verwendest, kannst du es eh komplett vergessen, auch
Affinity Designer und solche Sachen ist halt, ist halt RIP, so, mal gucken, ob es jetzt
ausgeschaltet ist, ah, okay, exellent, okay, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert es, jetzt können
wir den anderen Kram anschmeißen, so, wie kann man beschränken, was der crawlt gleichzeitig,
das kann man garantiert beschränken, das wäre ja bescheuert, ich mein, der macht wie viel,
24 Chromes gleichzeitig auf, das ist einfach zu viel, das muss man mal ein bisschen, ein
bisschen beschränken, Headless, jawoll, Incognito, no, Locked Level, Low Bandwidth, könnte man
vielleicht machen, ne, Open Browser muss übrigens auch zu, sonst kackt er uns wahrscheinlich
ab, Call, Page Timer, Protokoll Proxy, jetzt, wie, ich kann ihm nicht sagen, was der, wie
viel der parallel machen soll, ärztlich nett, ich kann Page Sleep, Page Backup einstellen,
aber kann ich nicht sagen, Max Concurrency oder irgendwie sowas, okay, das ist ja doof,
okay, das ist nett,
ja, okay, anscheinend geht das nicht, dann bleibt uns nichts anderes übrig, ne, Page
Sleep, Page Sleep ist zwischen den Seiten, der fängt trotzdem erstmal an alles parallel
zu machen, okay, das sollte sich nach einer Zeit wieder einpendeln, aber Leute wisst ihr
was, drauf geschissen, wir geben da jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen mehr Wumms, drei Kerne, 4G,
auf geht's und dazu müssen wir es runterfahren, oder, einfach mehr Hardware draufschmeißen,
Problem gelöst, kein Problem, gibt kein Problem, Power off, das habe ich ja noch nie gesehen,
was ist denn das, achso, ich will auch nicht Power Off machen, ich will Reboot machen,
jetzt hat es gecheckt, okay, okay, doch, ich wollte, ich kann, natürlich, was lasse ich
mir denn wieder von meinem Linux für Zeug einreden, natürlich wollte ich Power Off machen,
ich wollte Power Off machen, damit ich upgraden kann, Power Off, so, Bäm, so, wäre das nicht
möglich die Preise kleinzeitig abzurufen, weiß ich, nee, das geht wahrscheinlich nicht,
weil das wird von meinem Server aus aufgerufen, ich kann bestimmt nicht von der Seite, wenn
die über meinen Server aus aufgerufen wird, weil JavaScript hat ja da so seine Schutzmechanismen,
andere Domains getten, wenn die es nicht erlauben, und die erlauben es wahrscheinlich, nee, nee,
das wird nicht funktionieren, warum nicht via Selenium, das macht unter der Haube quasi
sowas ähnliches, so, Rescale, das ist mehr oder weniger das gleiche, die haben halt einen
kompletten ferngesteuerten Chrome, das kommt aber aus, kommt aber sehr ähnliche Sachen
raus, so, Rescale, volle Pulle, jetzt erstmal drei Kerne, erstmal drei Kerne, dann sollte
das bisschen schneller gehen, Server Typ is being changed, let's go, gib ihm, jetzt muss
erstmal einer ins Rechenzentrum rüberlaufen und die virtuelle CPU ausbauen, ok, haben wir
das geschafft, ok, das ist ne Windows, das ist so ne typische Windows-Leiste, wir haben
das das letzte Mal schon gemacht, das ging relativ schnell, in der Zeit kann ja wirklich
einer rüberlaufen, und warum sollte ich das deaktivieren, ah fertig, so, echt nice, Probetag,
sehr gut, exellent, was haben sie dich so gefragt, Lonax, so Bewerbungs, hast du dich beworben
für als Aztubi, denke ich mal, ne, ok, gucken wir jetzt mal, ob es funktioniert, was haben
wir, gucken, wie die Auslastung jetzt ist mit drei CPU-Kernen, just player, alles klar,
jetzt weiß ich Bescheid, so, ich will es gar nicht als Rute laufen lassen, das ist mir
so schon lieber, auf, gib Gas, starte, das erste mal, wie man, der Server aufbauen ist
schon lang vorbei, das dauert 5 Minuten, die Sache ist, mein, mein, mein, gedönster laufen
lassen, ist das andere Problem, ok, so, also, CPU-Auslastung, auf, gib ihm, jetzt ernsthaft,
der mache noch drei CPU-Kerne voll, ok, ich sehe schon, ich brauche eine extra Kiste
zum crawling, das kann man doch bestimmt irgendwie limitieren, das könnt ihr mir noch nicht
erzählen, Limit, kann das sein, dass ich selbst daran schuld bin, weil ich so viele
Shops da reingeschrieben habe, das müssen wir mal ausprobieren, der ist ganz schön
ausgelastet damit, ok, wir nehmen jetzt mal ein paar Sachen raus, also, store, komm, was
brauchen wir denn nicht, also, Amazon Alternate brauchen wir, AMD ist Schwachsinn erstmal,
Asus, Caseking, was nehmen wir davon mal raus hier, Equipper habe ich noch nie was von gehört,
Futurerex, da bestellt eh keiner GameStop, Ah, nicht, Media Markt, wobei wir machen das
anders, machen das anders, ich kopiere mir das, jetzt schmeiße ich es raus, also, AMD
kommt weg, AMD kommt weg, Caseking, Cyberport, Euronics, weiß ich nicht, ob da einer was
bestellt, Futurak, bestellt keine GameStop, auch weg, mein, Media Max, bestellt ihr mal
Media Max, da Otto, PC King, ProShop, da bestellt, Spielekarte können wir für Grafikkarten
auch wegmachen, ich nehme jetzt einfach mal die, wo ich weiß, dass ich auch schon was
bestellt habe, da habe ich bestellt, da habe ich bestellt, da habe ich bestellt, da habe
ich glaube ich meine CPU, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, Caseking habe ich schon was,
Cyberport, Euronics, Equipper, Alter, Equipper, Expert, Media Max, Otto, PC King, ProShop,
so, jetzt dürfte es ein bisschen weniger sein, JustPlayer, ich habe den Kram nicht programmiert,
das ist nicht der Teil, den ich selbst gebastelt habe, da habe ich keinen Einfluss drauf,
was der macht, außer ich patch da dran rum und das will ich nicht, so, vielleicht jetzt
ein bisschen weniger, auf, gib alles, was, ne, das juckt dir nicht, na doch, guck mal,
jetzt ist doch ein bisschen weniger, ne, oder auch nicht, what the fuck, was macht der da,
wie büroauslastungstechnisch ey, btf, das ist ganz schön hart das Ding, das ist nicht
fertig, das crawlt alle 10 Sekunden oder so, ich glaube es pendelt sich nach einer Zeit
ein, wenn ich ehrlich bin, ich glaube es pendelt sich nach einer Zeit ein, weil er startet halt
mit allen Seiten gleichzeitig, ok, wenn das keinen Unterschied macht, dann kann ich aber
auch alle Shops crawlen lassen, so, dann lasse ich jetzt einfach alle Shops crawlen wieder,
damn, ich brauch dann, ich brauch dann wahrscheinlich einen extra Server zum crawlen, ich meine,
ich könnte auch das Lokal laufen lassen bei mir, das crawlen und dann nur noch auf den
Server pushen, so, sehr gut, dann, dann darf der jetzt halt mal ein bisschen CPUlast verursachen,
alles gut, publish.net, pricechamp, gut, sehr schön, pricechamp ist am start, was, was
ist, ok, jetzt gehts, ja ja, die erste Verbindung geht immer kaputt, das ist ein Bug von der
Geschichte, so, und jetzt müssen wir mal testen, ob es funktioniert Leute, weil es
ist glaube ich nirgendwo eine 3060 verfügbar, also insofern, können wir vielleicht testen,
ob es funktioniert, wir können eine Fake Message posten, wir können eine Fake Message posten,
habe angegeben, dass ich einen PFsense und Server bereits habe, ja, PFsense ist auch
im Profiumfeld durchaus ab und zu mal anzutreffen, ja, bei uns haben sie auch fürs WLAN PFsense,
das weiß ich, WLAN für das, für das Portal, PFsense, High Class, zwischen Unmanaged und
Managed Switch, was macht man Ransomware Attacker, habe ich Ahnung von SAP, the fuck, warum fragt
man jemand, der eine Ausbildung machen will, ob er Ahnung von SAP hat, Rate 0, was das
ist, was Bitspeise, ganz schön viel, was die von dir wissen wollten, normalerweise lernt
man das in der Ausbildung, ja, ja, ich habe alle Shops drinne, alle Shops drinne, Notebooks
billiger hatten wir eigentlich auch drin, aber irgendwie macht er nur Computer Universe,
Equipers, Saturn, Media Markt, macht er sonst noch was, der macht doch gar nicht alle oder
und warum macht er nicht Amazon, seht ihr das, das sind doch nicht alle, aber es kann
sein, dass der alle, dass der die Shops erstmal alle durchmacht, warum geht das nicht, es
sind nur Media Markt, Computer Universe, Equipers und Case King gerade, hä, ich habe da da
total viel Zeug drinne stehen, das sind immer nur diese drei Dinger, muss man das jetzt
verstehen, ich pass die Shops nicht selbst, das ist ein fertiges Projekt von GitHub, ich
habe nur das Web Interface gebaut dazu, habe ich irgendwie mich vertippt, Amazon, ok, wir
kopieren das jetzt nochmal, also Amazon, wir machen jetzt einfach nur Amazon.de Alternate
Case King rein, so, davon vielleicht kein Leerzeichen machen, Leerzeichen zwischen,
das ist vielleicht kaputt, es kann auch sein, dass der erstmal alles durchmacht, wie heißt
das Projekt Street Merchant, was da auch mit schlechtem ASCII A drinne steht, Case King,
ok, wo ist Amazon, sag mal Leute, was, Selected Stores, Amazon Alternate Case King, warum
checkt der jetzt nur Case King, kann das sein, ach wisst ihr warum, nur die Dinger, nur die
Dinger, die eine 3060 haben, checkt der natürlich, die meisten haben einfach keine 3060, warte
mal Leute, wir gucken einfach mal, wer eine 3060 hat, wer hat eine 3060 hier, grab 3060,
ach ne, das ist falsch, ich bin ja auch verkehrt, Store, nicht eine 363060, wenn ich eine 3060
hätte, wenn ich jetzt auch noch richtig schreiben würde, CD Store, aber ich war noch richtig,
grab 3060, ok, also, seht ihr mal, ok, deswegen geht das nicht, also was für Shops haben
wir Leute, lass mal kurz aufschreiben, also, was haben wir, das ist kein deutscher Shop,
das ist, wir suchen einfach mal, grab, grab.de,.de,.de, also Equipper, also Equipper, schauen
wir mal ob an, Case King, wie nur die zwei, Moment, hab ich, wer ist da nicht drin, was
hab ich, hab ich die letzte Variante, 3, was ist v, 3, kann es sein, dass nur zwei Shops,
zwei Shops diese Karte überhaupt drin haben, kann natürlich sein, ich guck jetzt mal kurz
mal den auf GitHub, aber Amazon hat doch garantiert, ok, guck mal mal hier, also, Main, der hat
übrigens schon Main nicht, Master, Source, Store, Model, oh, Mind Factory, 3060, ach
so, die haben einfach keine 3060 drin, Case King, vPoint, Equipper, Ollo, Zotac, ach ok,
das ergibt natürlich Sinn, ja, ja, dann kann das auch nicht funktionieren, ja gut, dann
müssen wir jetzt mit diesen zwei Dingern das machen, Store, also Amazon, aber Amazon nicht
Amazon.de, Asus, ja geil, es ist, es ist in Deutschland wirklich nur, es ist nur Equipper,
Computer Universe, die nicht.de haben, by the way, Saturn, ah Saturn hat auch, oder was,
ok, da müssen wir den Kram jetzt doch mal kurz von Hand durchgucken, also, ok, fang
mal an, Amazon, ich schreib's mir mal nebenbei auf, was wir haben, also Amazon, Amazon, Asus,
Canada Computers, Case King, Computer Universe, Equipper, immer Equipper ist, Media Markt,
EVGA, sag mal, wenn ich irgendwas deutsches übersehe, Neueck, Neueck gibt's nicht in
China, Overclockers, Overclockers, Overclockers, ProShop, Saturn, Zotac, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok
Probieren das jetzt aus. Run.
Ja, ich hab ja auch nicht nur deutsche Shops drinne.
Man kann ja bestimmt auch Baasos international bestellen und nach Deutschland schippen, das ist kein Problem.
In Sendero geht, musst du geht Pull machen, ja.
Okay, was haben wir?
EVGA ist deprecated.
Ah, das sieht schon besser aus.
Equipa, Caseking, Asus, Computer Universe, jetzt kommt der ganze Mist.
Okay, alles klar.
Execution Contrast, Context was destroyed.
Bäm.
Gut, es ist überall out of stock, sehr schön.
Das heißt, wir können jetzt auf dem, auf Preischamp nichts sehen, aber ich kann mal eine Fake Message schicken.
Ich kann, ich kann mal eine Fake Message schicken.
Hammerle Linux Frage, hab mir auf WSL 2 ein ZS-H-Shell eingereicht.
Gibt es irgendwelche Bedenken, dass ich das nicht auch auf meinem Root-Server installieren sollte? Nö.
Der DSR kannst du da auch wunderbar installieren.
So.
Dann schicken wir doch mal eine Fake Message und gucken, ob es das anzeigt.
Ich mach jetzt noch mal aus und wir schicken eine Fake Message.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das ordentlich programmiert hab, dass ihr das so erkennt.
Ich schick mal eine Test-Message und wir gucken mal, ob die hier ankommt.
Oh, was jetzt?
Nicht verfügbar.
Fuck.
Warum, aber warum?
Äh, what, what, what?
Okay, das hab ich nicht getestet.
Ich hab's vorhin getestet mit einer Message, die einen Case-King-Link enthalten hat und damit hat's funktioniert.
Dann ist es auf grün gewechselt.
Wisst ihr was, wir lassen es jetzt einfach auf grün.
Vielleicht kommt ja eine in Stock.
Ich kann mal so eine.
Wo ist denn hier noch mal da, wo ich die Message sende?
Background-Services, Street-Merchant-Alert.
Jawoll, alles klar.
Da kommt das rein.
Street-Merchant-Merchant-Alert.
Dann guck ich Price.
Ah, der Price geht nicht.
Der Price kackt ab, deswegen geht's nicht.
Ha.
Oder?
Heck wait.
Jaja, das Frontend trifft recht automatisch, wenn eine in Stock ist.
Instant.
Hab ich vorhin ausprobiert, wenn man die richtige Message schickt.
Aber aktuell ist ja alles nicht in Stock.
Okay, wir probieren mal, wir probieren mal Fake-Messages.
Okay, wir probieren mal, wir probieren mal Fake-mäßig was zu schicken.
Wir versuchen Fake-mäßig was zu schicken.
Und zu gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Äh.
Price.
Wir schicken mal eine MQTT-Message.
Und gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Pupp.
Also, wir publishen eine Message.
Local Host.
Topic.
Street-Merchant-Alert.
Und sagen jetzt,
keine Ahnung, Message.
Kack weh.
Oder sollte jetzt?
Eigentlich, das darfst du. Guck hier.
Ah, Alert. Kack weh.
So.
Und jetzt tragen wir mal was ein.
Was funktioniert.
Was funktionieren könnte.
Oh.
What the fuck.
Wo ist das jetzt noch?
Okay.
Also.
Test-Print.
NVIDIA. Ich muss jetzt irgendwas reinschreiben, was so aussieht,
als könnte es funktionieren.
Und, Uel interessiert mich nicht.
Model interessiert mich Model.
Mich interessiert
nur Pran und Sirius.
Model interessiert
mich auch nicht.
Price interessiert mich.
Ah, das ist das Problem, weil
es Doppelpunkt 100 drin steht.
Nee, das ist, nee, nee.
Das ist richtig.
Keine Ahnung, mal hier 100.
Sirius.
30, 60, CI.
Name.
Kack weh Shop.
Warum geht denn das nicht?
Hab ich doch vorhin ausprobiert.
Brand.
Warum ist das nicht verfügbar?
Oh.
Das hab ich vorhin ausprobiert, das hat funktioniert.
Musst du eine Test-Message schicken
und dann ist es grün geworden.
Hm.
Geht denn das jetzt nicht
mehr? Ich schick garantiert
irgendwas verkehrt hier. Updated
Add. Price.
Funktioniert der Websocket.
Frage ob der Websocket
müsste eigentlich funktionieren, sonst müsste es
Fehlermeldungen geben.
Aber wir können das ausprobieren.
Wir können das ausprobieren.
Was.
wheelchair.
He.
Äh.
Also, jetzt habe so der Websocket
Die Websocket funktioniert, weil sonst gibt es einen Connection-Fehler und hier sieht man auch, dass der Websocket prinzipiell tut.
Ähm, wisst ihr was? Ich schalte das Debug-Ding nochmal an. Ich bin jetzt echt verwirrt, dass es nicht geht. Ich mach jetzt das Debug-Tool nochmal an.
Hallo? Shutdown please? Warum könnte das jetzt sein, dass es nicht geht?
Weil wenn ich das jetzt schon, dann will ich zumindest, dass die Basics-Sachen tun, dass es einfach grün wird. Ist zwar jetzt nicht sonderlich sinnvoll, dass es nur eine Grafikkarte kann, aber ich wollte eigentlich heute nur mal gucken, ob es funktioniert und es funktioniert ja noch nicht mal.
Seine G-Bate-Webseite, da steht immer nicht verfügbar.
Ok. Nice-Champ.
Ok, der kann sich da auf jeden Fall schon mal connecten. Der kann das Fetchen ja. Schema, ja, Subscription, On-Product-Snapshot und da rufen wir jetzt, keine Ahnung, Brand, ID, Prices, mir doch egal.
Was? So, Subscription.
Irgendwas mach ich verkehrt. Mein Fake Alert geht nicht. Brand, Price, Serious, Name, Update sollte aber eigentlich gehen.
Also der schickt keine Antwort drauf.
Hä? Warum, was hab ich denn jetzt verkehrt gemacht? Ich schick den Kram hier los? Price?
Schau mal die Message aus. Hab ich da einen Sündagsfehler drin oder so?
Ist da irgendwo ein schönes Sündagsfehler drin?
Ja das Problem ist, nur weil Sachen lokal funktionieren, heißt das noch lang nicht, dass die auch so...
Also das ist auf jeden Fall das Problem.
Ich mach mal ein paar Prints rein, weil ich grad nicht so genau weiß, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Da oben mach ich mal wieder aus, den brauchen wir jetzt nicht. Und kopieren wir mal neu hin.
Ja, sehr merkwürdig. Ich hab da garantiert irgendwie einen Logikfehler drin, dass meine Testmessage nicht funktioniert.
Ich hätte mir die Testmessage mal speichern sollen von vorhin.
Aber an sich soll es... Guck mal hier. Brand, Price, Serious? Name? Cool?
Gut, Update Ed verwende ich nicht. Komisch.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen Debug-Ausgabe kriegen, warum es nicht geht.
Die Message kommt auf jeden Fall an, das sieht man schon mal. Guck da. Bad 2 hängt da.
Der kann die Datenbank nicht speichern. Warum das denn?
Ach, ich bin doof. Guck mal, was ich vergessen habe. Lull.
Der legt gar keine Datenbank an. Ja, jetzt war klar, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Unit-Tests. Unit-Tests für Noobs. Print-Line-Debugging. Machen die Profis, siehst du hier.
Und ich bin Profi, ich verdiene mal Geld damit. Das sollte jetzt über jeden Zweifel erhaben sein, oder?
Starten wir mal den Kram wieder. Raus hier.
Ich habe vergessen die Datenbank anzulegen. Aha, okay. Ja, das ergibt Sinn, dass es nicht funktioniert dann.
Aber Leute, pass mal auf, jetzt wird es funktionieren. Predictions. Predictions. Meine es geht oder meine es geht nicht?
Ich sag, es geht jetzt.
Price-Camp gestartet.
Price-Camp ist geladen. Price-Camp reloaden. Price-Camp Subscription Attach.
Der KekW-Shop. Es funktioniert, Leute. Kaum legt er die Datenbank an, klappt es.
Also Leute, 3060Ti ist im KekW-Shop verfügbar.
Gleich acht bestellt. So mag ich das. So mag ich das.
Okay, jetzt können wir die ganzen Crap hier wieder raus machen, weil eigentlich hat alles funktioniert, was ich gemacht habe.
So, sehr gut. Gut. Dann können wir jetzt ja die Sache einfach mal ein bisschen laufen lassen und gucken, was passiert.
Und ich mach das so, ich sag nicht deleted. Ich sag nicht deleted. Ich will ja nämlich eine Price-History haben.
Nur created soll das sicherstellen. Jetzt kopieren wir noch mal hin und jetzt lass ichs laufen.
Exzellent. Was machst du? Warum keine Preise? Ach stimmt, hab ich da keine Preise drauf?
Oh ne, das müssen wir ändern. Preismuster drauf. Ohne Preis ist doof.
Machen wir abbrechen. Da muss ein Preis drauf. Ohne Preis ist kacke.
Jaja, nervt nicht rum. Also Shop Name. Local Timestamp. Wie heißt denn der Kram? Ich hoffe es heißt einfach nur Price.
Preis will ich nicht kapitalieren. Preis.
Noch ein Euro Zeichen. Jedenfalls bestimmt Euro.
Das Impressum. Ich verdiene damit nichts und außerdem ist es eine Ork Seite.
Ja, ich quäle euch jetzt gleich mit DSGVO-Bannern. Wenn ihr weiter macht, mach ich euch das DSGVO-Banner drauf.
Ok, jetzt haben wir das. Jetzt können wir es kopieren. Und jetzt sollte alles funktionen.
Cookie Popup auch noch. Gibt es eigentlich noch ein fertiges DSGVO-Banner?
View Cookie Law. Exzellent. 10.000 Weekly Downloads. Ok, das ist beliebt. Cookie Law.
Das werden wir gleich nachdem alles läuft noch integrieren. Packt doch Werbung auf die Seite. Ich mach da vielleicht bei Amazon Reflings nachher.
Aber, also nachher wenn es dann funktioniert. What the fuck, was ist mit meinem Terminal los?
So, haben wir fertig kopiert. Preis-Champ. Ok, und jetzt mal abschließend Kontrolle, ob es funktioniert. Preis-Champ reloaden.
Ok, da ist der Preis-Champ. Guck mal hier. Responsive Preis-Champ.
So, Preis-Champ läuft. Und jetzt kommt eine Grafikkarte rein. Bam.
Was hab ich denn wieder kaputt gemacht? Bei dir gings? Ernsthaft? Gings bei euch Leute? Wow.
Ah, jetzt gehts. Äh, ok. Was auch immer, vor für Effekt. By the way, der resetet sich nicht. Der resetet sich nicht.
Äh, ich hab nichts eingebaut, was im Hintergrund das Ding nach 5 Minuten wieder auf rot schaltet oder so. Das ist wirklich der absolute Basics.
Ja, F5 ist klar. Der hat keinerlei, der ruft sich noch keinerlei State ab. Wenn du nicht die Seite aufhast, während es verfügbar wird, dann ist nicht grün.
Wie gesagt, ey, ich hab das in 3,5 Stunden zusammengewurst in den ganzen Kram. Ich werd's so machen, dass es timeoutet.
Nach einer Viertelstunde gehts wieder auf rot, wenn in der Zwischenzeit es halt nicht wieder auf grün gegangen ist.
So. Oh nein, jetzt hab ich's ausgeschaltet. Ich war im falschen, falschen, falschen T-Max drinnen.
Soll ich nochmal neu starten? Kannst du ne Mail schicken? Jaja, kann ich, aber jetzt in der Version hier grad nicht.
Das ist ja einfach nur zum gucken, ob es irgendwie in irgendeiner Art und Weise funktioniert. Ok, das funktioniert mit Nachrichten.
So, gut, ähm. Dann starten wir mal das Crawlen und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was ich für ein Traffic bis morgen früh verursacht hab.
Was, ähm, ob man das überhaupt sieht auf Hetzner schon.
So ein Ding für die 3080, das kann 3080, 3090, 3060, Playstation 5, Xbox und Ryzen CPUs.
Ich hab jetzt grad eine Sache draufstehen, damit ich gucken kann, ob es funktioniert.
Und das Gute ist, dadurch, dass ich das Crawlen nicht selbst programmiert hab, muss ich einfach nur die neueste GitHub-Version laden und ich hab die neuesten Dinger am Start.
Das ist äußerst praktisch.
Die Crawl-Time, das hab ich mir schon gedacht, die Crawl-Time runterzustellen, aber sie haben keine gescheiten Settings,
die haben Page-Backup-Time und sowas für. Achso, naja, gut, das ist aus. Aber das ist nicht so, nicht so geil. Das crawlt alle 10 Sekunden.
Bin mal gespannt, wie groß die Datenbank morgen ist. Mal gucken, wie groß die Datenbank morgen ist, ich mein.
Da geht ja dann, wobei, aktuell ist ja nichts verfügbar, also wird die Datenbank auch nicht belastet.
By the way, wisst ihr, was wir machen könnten? Oh, ange-
Leute, PostChamp, Asus ist verfügbar.
Temporary Sold-Out, Scam-Arst, gescampt, Leute.
Gescampt.
Der KQW-Shop ist wieder da. Aber ihr seht, es hätte funktioniert.
Ah, da steht kein Preis drin. Weil das Ding nicht richtig crawlt, oder was?
Ey, guck mal, das buggt. Der Asus doch buggt. Aber das Coole ist, aus irgendwelchen Gründen zeigt das nicht an.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil der Preis nicht drin steht.
Ich glaube, das liegt daran, weil der Preis nicht drin steht. Dann checkt das irgendwie nicht.
Wartet mal. Ich muss das gerade mal überprüfen, ob das jetzt-
Ich poste jetzt mal diese Message da von Hand rein und gucke, ob es dann anschlägt.
Ob das am Preis liegt. Ja, okay. Das geht nicht. Screenshot? Oh fuck, Screenshots muss ich ausmachen.
Ich probiere mal kurz, ob es am Preis liegt.
Preis.
100. Es liegt am Preis, okay. Wenn der Preis nicht drin steht, dann zeigt er nichts an.
Was auch ganz gut ist.
Warum eigentlich? Warum zeigt er da nichts an?
Warum zeigt er da nichts an?
Ich muss das nochmal ausmachen, weil ich muss die Screenshots ausschalten.
Ansonsten ist die Festplatte gleich voll.
Er speichert nämlich Screenshots von der Webseite, wo er was gefunden hat.
Und das Blöde ist, wenn er- Der buggt ja ab und zu mal rum.
Und er soll auf jeden Fall keine Screenshots speichern, sonst ist die Platte voll.
Genau, warum verschickt er denn?
Contains Price.
Und wenn es kein Preis erkennt, dann ist es not a number.
Ah, vielleicht kann er not a number- Oh, wobei. Das sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Ah gut, das kann ich lokal ausprobieren.
Ich starte das Ding jetzt einfach wieder.
Und lasse es mal ein bisschen laufen und guck mal, wie es morgen so gelaufen ist.
Der KekW-Shop ist aber gut dabei hier.
Gut, ich lasse es mal laufen und guck mal, wie es über Nacht funktioniert.
Der Preis-Champ, Beta-Preis-Champ am Start.
Übrigens, die Exception kommt immer, wenn eine Session time-outet.
Ist auch bescheuert, ist auch ein Bug von dem Teil.
So, jetzt einfach mal gucken, wie das läuft, ob das halbwegs gescheit funktioniert.
Was so die CPU lasst, dann sagt morgen.
Und dann weiß ich schon mal mehr.
Jetzt gehe ich noch mal lokal bei mir in die Repos rein.
Probier das mal lokal aus.
Warum das nicht funktioniert hat mit der Asus-Message.
Das wundert mich jetzt.
Nee, das ist kein Bot.
Was du machen kannst, ist, du kannst bei manchen Sachen direkt auf den Shopping-Card klicken.
Das geht.
Hetzner denkt, du meinst Bitcoins.
Das kann schon sein, aber Hetzner ist das egal.
Hetzner kriegt da Geld für.
Nur mal kurz schauen, warum der Kram nicht funktioniert.
Localhost 8080.
Warum der Kram...
Moment, Moment, jetzt muss ich natürlich erst mal auch lokal aufmachen.
Ich müsste da mal eine Logik einbauen, dass der...
dass der checkt, ob er lokal ist und dann die URL ändert, weil so ist ziemlich doof.
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Weil der hat ja hier...
irgendwo, wo war das hier? Da stand jetzt immer Beta-Preis-Champ drin.
Das ist natürlich nicht so toll.
Kann man nicht irgendwie checken, if environment production, dann...
geht doch bestimmt.
Moment, das hab ich doch hier auf GitHub in dem Kamerading schon gemacht.
Monarch S. Monarch S und dann...
Client App.
Source, wo muss ich hin?
View Apollo.
Die haben da echt immer...
Genau, hier, Process Node Enth, exellent, genau das.
Das hab ich doch schon zusammengebastelt.
Wenn Development dann local, genau, das.
Das brauchen wir.
Wenn Development dann local, ansonsten das da.
HTTP.
Das da.
Okay, das müsste jetzt da eins tun.
Schauen wir mal, ob er das jetzt gecheckt hat.
Kennt es Tablish? Ach so, GraphQL hab ich vergessen.
Und es ist auch nicht... Nee, Port 5000 ist richtig.
Port 5000 ist korrekt.
Das funktioniert wahrscheinlich deswegen nicht.
Das ist ein Bug in Chrome.
Genau, jetzt funktioniert's.
Jetzt geht's.
Genau, wenn man localhost verwendet, geht das in Chrome.
Ich frag mich bitte nicht, warum.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, jetzt kann ich es lokal mal probieren.
Mos, Pub, localhost, nee, Asus, Pub.
Jetzt gucken wir mal, warum das Kram nicht tut.
Das sollte jetzt lokal funktionieren.
Ja, okay.
Und wenn ich das mehrfach update, dann stimmt auch die Zeit.
So, okay, und warum ging das jetzt mit Asus nicht?
Das ist jetzt die Preisfrage. Warum geht das mit Asus nicht?
Nee, mit Asus tut das einfach nicht. Aber warum?
Nö. Mit Asus juckt ihn das nicht mit dem Asus Store.
Aber warum?
Das liegt am Preis. Also, das wissen wir schon.
Das wissen wir. Das liegt auf jeden Fall am Preis.
Aber warum? Was ist hier an meiner Logik fail mit dem Preis?
Was ist das für ein Bild? Das Bing Image of the Day.
Lass mich raten. Der macht das hier gar nicht.
Darf ich jetzt restarten?
Ich kann mir immer nicht merken, ob es.net run watch oder.net watch run ist.
Ich glaube, es ist.net watch run.
Was ist das für ein neuer Pokchamp? Zeig mal, was ist der neue Pokchamp?
Ach, hier. Pokchamp. Ich muss sagen, Kripp war der beste Pokchamp bisher.
Okay.
So, schauen wir mal. Was ist jetzt, wenn ich dir das abschicke?
Asus. Ja.
Ich weiß. Kann das sein?
Leute, kann das sein, dass Entity Framework Not a Number nicht serialisieren kann?
Kann es sein, dass der Not hier, der hat ja Preis, ist ja ein Float, dass der None nicht serialisieren kann?
Probier mal aus. Machen wir mal Null. Wir machen mal Null.
Pass mal auf. Mal gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Jetzt geht's. Oh, WTF. Das ist ja bescheuert.
Warum kann er Not a Number? Das heißt, ein gültiger Floatwert oder was heißt gültiger?
Ein gültiger, ungültiger Floatwert kann er nicht serialisieren. Okay, das war mir jetzt neu.
Das wusste ich nicht. Zack. Asus.
Das wusste ich nicht. Aber Null ist keine gute Idee.
Ich mache einen negativen Preis. Ich muss ja herausfinden, ob der Preis gesetzt ist oder nicht.
Mach mal Minus. Was gibt es denn für eine gute Sache, für einen Float irgendwie was zu symbolisieren, wenn es es nicht gibt?
Not a Number bringt es das an der Stelle. Da muss ich das überall checken.
Ein Preis von Null heißt eigentlich, es ist kostenlos. Wie wäre es mit Minus eins oder so?
Minus eins. Wir machen Minus eins. Genau, wir machen Minus eins und dann sagen wir hier
Preis. Diff. Das zeigen wir nur, wenn Snapshot Price größer.
Ist das jetzt ein String, was das zurückkommt? Hoffentlich nicht. Größer Null. So, easy.
Zack. Wait. Ach so, Moment. Ich bin ja auch nur loop, ich habe das gar nicht reinkopiert.
Alles klar, gut, passt. Geht. Wir könnten das jetzt noch so machen. Ja, okay, alles klar.
Funst. Link zum ASUS Store Funst auch. Das Ding kann anscheinend den Preis hier nicht passen. Okay, sehr gut. Dann passt das ja.
Dann werde ich das jetzt noch mal pushen. Der ASUS, Leute, der ASUS Store ist verbackt.
Der ASUS Store sagt permanent, es ist verfügbar, dabei ist es gar nicht verfügbar. Kirk, wait. Der ASUS Store ist verbackt.
Okay, ich push jetzt noch mal. Da können wir nämlich gleich mal sehen, wie es blinkt und dass es auch funktioniert.
Weil man sieht, unten ist es nicht verfügbar. By the way, soll ich mal Playstation und Gedöns noch mit rein machen? Hallo.
Chat, DDoS ist raus, oder? Gibt es zu? Gibt es zu?
Also ich kann auf der Webseite gerade noch nichts anderes anzeigen lassen. Das ist halt einfach nur in dreieinhalb Stunden hingewürzt.
Und ich habe jetzt eine Sache halt reingeschrieben. Auf der anderen Seite, ich meine, was ich machen kann ist,
was ich echt machen kann ist, das ist für die 360 TI. Man könnte eine 360 noch rein machen. Das ist halt überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht.
Da müsste ich das jetzt umreden. Last Snapshot 3060, Last Snapshot 3070. Der Host da, der Host da kriegt Geld dafür.
Da soll ich mal gar nicht beschweren. So. Also ich werde da jetzt aber einbauen, dass der die ganzen Dinger kann.
Also wie gesagt, das Tool unterstützt Konsolen und unterstützt alle aktuellen AMD CPUs und sonst was.
Das heißt, ihr könnt euch schon mal Beta-Preis-Champ merken. Bam, Asus ist verfügbar. Und jetzt klickt man drauf.
You got jebaited, weil der Asus dort verbugt ist. Er denkt, es ist in Stock, aber es ist nicht in Stock.
Guckt, er denkt, es ist in Stock, aber es ist nicht in Stock. Ist halt ein bisschen verbugt.
Aber dafür, dass ich den Kram, das untere, nicht selbst programmieren muss, bin ich ganz froh drum.
Da bin ich echt insofern ganz froh drum, weil da könnte ich niemals up to date bleiben mit Seiten-Crawler. Im Leben nicht.
Im Leben nicht.
Okay. Asus hat eine Crawler-Protection? Nee, ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das Programm hat einfach einen Bug, was Asus angeht.
Intel ist mittlerweile für Preis-Champ, ja. Wie heißt der Crawler? Street Merchant.
Der Chat kann die Captures lösen. Nee, ich hole mir einen Chinesen auf Fiverr, der macht das.
Okay. Ha, Asus ist mal wieder da. Go, go, schnell kaufen, Leute. Ganz schnell, beeilt euch.
Zack, zack. Instant Buy. Wie gesagt, das resetet sich nicht. Eigentlich müsste sich das nach 5 Minuten resetten.
So, ich mache es nochmal lokal auf. Asus lieber rausnehmen, wenn es so verbugt ist. Ich habe es jetzt absichtlich drin, dass ich sehe, dass mein Kram funktioniert.
So, wir machen jetzt mal was Folgendes. Also, irgendjemand wollte eine 3070 haben. Ich versuche mal eine Sache noch zu machen. Ist das selbstgeschrieben oder library? Teils, teils. Also das Webinterface und alles, was er dafür braucht, ist von mir. Der Crawler ist Street Merchant von GitHub.
Und der Crawler schickt eine Message raus zu meiner Anwendung. So, wir können jetzt nochmal was ausprobieren.
Local Horst. Schiebe das mal kurz um. Also wir könnten... Last Snapshot. Aktuell gibt es ja bei mir nur 3060.
Das heißt, ich könnte auch sowas hier machen. Last Snapshot 3060. Da müsste ich aber halt checken, ob es 3060 ist oder nicht. Oder ich mache einen Array. Last Snapshots.
Da müsste ich aber wieder uniken auf das Produkt. Das ist auch doof. Dann filter ich mal lieber hier raus. Nee, ich mache einfach eine Dictionary mit der Serious. Das ist gut. Das ist gut. Das können wir machen. Also, easy.
Warte, Arkom. Konnte das Ding nicht Arkom? Das müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Arkom? Arkom. Easy.
Ah, aber die haben die 3060 von Arkom noch nicht drin. Heals Batman. Also ich überlege gerade, wie wir das hier reinkriegen. Ich könnte doch Last Snapshot...
Wie macht man ein Dictionary in Javascript? Ich glaube, das macht man mit Objects. Also, dass ich dann quasi sage... In das. How to create key value. Genau. So. Okay.
Also sprich, ich kann doch jetzt sagen. Last Snapshots. Mehrzahl. So. Snapshot. Serious.
Das heißt, jetzt habe ich hier immer den letzten Snapshot drinne stehen. Das letzte Produktinfo zu einer gewissen Grafikkartentyp. Also immer der letzte Eintrag für 3060, 3070, 3080, 3090.
Das können wir noch jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert. Da können wir das vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen erweitern, dass das jetzt mal so rudimentär sogar ein bisschen mehr anzeigt als nur 3060 TI.
Also Last Snapshot Serious. Snapshot ist hier so. Dann müssen wir das hier eigentlich löschen. Und das ist hier this. A Snapshot. Genau. Is not defined. Kann man irgendwie hier dann die Elemente in so einem Dictionary zählen?
Wie macht man das ordentlich in JavaScript, ey? Gar nicht, oder? Kann man das zählen? Okay, das probiere ich jetzt mal aus. Wir starten jetzt mal. Ich bin ja nicht der Große.
Wir starten jetzt mal eine Node und sagen jetzt hier, okay, let blob gleich das da. Die Einträge in meinem Dictionary. Das ist ja gar kein Dictionary. Das ist ja ein JavaScript Object. Das ist ja das Problem dabei.
So. Kann ich noch Keys? Keys?
Size ist doch für einen.
JS Count Keys. Object. Was ist das? JavaScript ist immer für eine Überraschung gut. Null. Okay. Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sage Blob.
CacW gleich eins kommt eins hinten raus. Size. Nee. Object. Alles klar. Okay. Verstanden. Verstanden. Object. Keys. Length brauche ich.
Sehr gut. Die Logik. JavaScript Logik habe ich nicht verstanden, aber dann passt das schon mal.
So. Das heißt, jetzt checke ich hier. Nee. Ha. Ich checke einfach. Last Snapshots. Serious ist 3060 te.
Und wenn das gleich null ist, dann. Weil wenn ich was abfrage aus diesem Dictionary, was es nicht gibt, dann kommt null raus, oder? Nee, da kommt undefined raus.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen null und undefined in JavaScript jetzt schon wieder?
Das funktioniert auch so. Das funktioniert auch so.
Probieren wir mal. Probieren wir mal, ob das noch alles tut.
Pup. Pup. Das funktioniert jetzt nicht. Aha.
Nein, nein, nein. Ich Leute, ich rede doch nicht von von null einer Zahl. Ich rede von null.
So. Okay, mal Lock. Lock. Was da reinkommt.
Serious 3060 te. Okay.
Dann sollte das doch eigentlich funktionieren. Das Checked View bestimmt nicht, oder?
Das das das Checked View bestimmt nicht, um Reactive zu sein, wenn ich das hier so wenn ich das hier so abfrage.
Weil eigentlich müsste das checken.
Eigentlich müsste es das kapieren.
Gehen wir mal aus. Lock.
Wisst ihr, was wir machen? Wir machen jetzt einfach Big Brain, weil True 2.
Da kriege ich jetzt einfach einen auf den Dinger geschickt. Exzellent. Perfekt.
360. Das Checked View nicht. Fuck.
Guck, das ist nämlich der Key. Das müsste das müsste das eigentlich kapieren. Wie mach ich denn so was in View, um da jetzt zu gucken, ob dem Dictionary was drin ist?
Ich glaube, da checkt nicht, dass das Reactive ist. Passt mal auf, denn das das wird da nicht kapieren.
Hallo?
Ja.
Der sollte das nicht eigentlich weiter schicken als nur einmal.
Guck, der checkt nicht, dass das das nicht das ist nicht Reactive. So also Moment, warum führt er das jetzt hier nur?
Echo.
Okay, der führt das aus.
Okay, funktioniert alles gut. Okay, View checkt das nicht. Das muss ich anders machen.
Nee, nee, nee, das funktioniert so nicht. Das sieht man allein schon daran, dass er hier nicht updatet. Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie View Set oder sowas machen. Das ist wieder ganz wäre JavaScript Magic, Leute. Das hatte ich schon ein paar Mal.
View Set Array. Das kriegt View nicht mit, dass das, dass sich das ändert.
Genau, das da will ich haben.
View Set State Object. State Object ist die Snapshots. Key ist Serious. Value ist Snapshot. Das will ich machen. Jetzt checkt das auch.
So, das ist Dollar View. War das so?
Ja, gute Frage. Einfach nur Set wirklich? Nee, oder?
Wie war das jetzt nochmal?
Macht es halt noch komplizierter hier.
VMSet. What?
This.
Was einfach, was Punkt Dollar Set?
Wirklich?
Ich weiß, was das in dem Kontext ist. Keine Ahnung.
Das muss funktionieren, sonst wird das hier nicht klappen. Das muss klappen, sonst wird das nicht gehen.
Gibt es denn die Funktion überhaupt?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Ich muss das ja auch nicht setzen. Ich setze es ja damit.
Wo ist denn jetzt das Problem schon wieder?
This Snapshots. Warum mag er das jetzt nicht?
Er mag das nicht, weil Last Snapshot ist undefined.
Moment, das kommt woanders her. Leute, das ist ein anderer Fehler.
Das ist ein anderer Fehler. Das liegt nicht daran. Das funktioniert hier alles.
Es funktioniert alles.
Last Snapshots. Guck, es funktioniert alles. Alles gut, alles gut.
Was nicht funktioniert, ist der restliche Crap. Das probieren wir jetzt gerade mal aus.
Guck, jetzt update er. Jetzt update er. Es funktioniert prinzipiell.
Alles gut, funktioniert. Jetzt update er.
Jetzt muss ich nur den anderen Kram richtig machen.
Blablabla. Last Snapshots. Alles ok.
Last Snapshot ti gleich 0. Das funktioniert jetzt nämlich nicht an der Stelle.
Muss ich nämlich sagen, dass da.
Wenn das gleich 0 ist, dann sagt er nicht verfügbar. Genau.
Jetzt will er nämlich ins else rein und das else funktioniert nicht.
Wenn ich das hier alles weg mache, dann wird es klappen.
Dann wird es einfach grün ohne Text. Genau.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt diesen Crap hier nehmen. Das ist absolut nicht schön, aber ok.
Excellent. Gut, funktioniert.
Loop doch über die Serien. Sehr gute Idee. Ja, das wäre das nächste gewesen.
Noch besser.
Dann können wir nämlich den ganzen Kram dynamisch machen hier. Sehr gut, das machen wir jetzt.
Also wir machen hier mal einen diff.
Woop pock, also im Prinzip ab hier.
V. Loop.
Jetzt natürlich die große Preisfrage. Wie loop ich denn da drüber?
Kies. Loop over keys object js.
Entries. Alter, JavaScript macht mich fertig. Das ist so unintuitiv an manchen Stellen.
Moment, das brauche ich ja gar nicht, ich brauche nur das da. Object Entries.
Wie gesagt, das könnte man eigentlich noch schöner mit dem computed property oder so machen, aber ich will erst mal gucken, ob es tut.
Vor wie ging das view vor vor in objects.
Wie ging das view loop? Steht gerade auf dem Schlauch. Wie vor items in items. Ach ja.
Items in object.
Last snapshots.
Messages gibt es nicht. Key ist mein Key.
Okay, sehr schön, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Das heißt, da kriege ich jetzt eine eins oder irgendwie sowas wenigstens raus jetzt. Jawoll, sehr gut.
Das heißt, ich kann diesen ganzen Crap da jetzt reinpacken.
Mit dem Alert. Moment.
Das da kann ich alles reinpacken und jetzt wird es dynamisch gerendert für alles, was drin ist.
Sonst sage ich nämlich last snapshots weg. Prinzip nur noch.
Wenn.
Ungleich null muss ich. Moment.
Nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Weil wenn nichts drinne steht, dann steht es gar nicht auf der Seite drauf.
Ich will ja, dass es also nicht verfügbar drauf steht, wenn es auf der Seite steht. Es funktioniert so nicht.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Wieder rückgängig.
Ich meine, wir könnten.
Wir machen das einfach anders. Wir hardcoden das einfach.
Oder?
Wir können das einfach hardcoden, die Dinger, die es gibt.
Also dass wir sagen.
Es gibt eine 3060 TI.
Die ist halt standardmäßig leer.
Oder auch.
Ja, die standardmäßig leer.
Es gibt eine 3080.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was das alles kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Was, was, was, was, was unterstützen die hier alles?
Wat?
Ich bin falsch.
Wo ist es denn?
Street.
Was unterstützen die denn hier alles?
Ganz filter.
Also die können eine 3060, 3070, 38, 3090.
38, 30, 90. Okay, dann bauen wir doch das mal ein. Dann bauen wir das doch mal ein. Also
Wir haben nur 30, 70
Das ist auch leer. Wir können das einfach mal kopieren. Wir machen das jetzt mal für die Grafikkarten. So, 30, 70
30, 80 und ich muss das TI noch weg machen. 30, 90
Gut, genau und jetzt jetzt kann ich das mit der Schleife nämlich machen
Ja, das sieht schon besser aus. Jetzt kann ich das mit der Schleife nämlich machen
Und jetzt ist die Überschrift ist jetzt
Item Serious
Äh, ne, key, key, einfach nur. Einfach nur, äh, what the?
Äh, äh, äh
Warum ist es ein Error? Ah, weil es Entries ist. Ah
Ah
Ne, warum ist es denn Error? Hä?
Was, was
Es muss, das sollte ein Objekt sein. Das sollte ein Objekt sein mit, what the?
Ah, JavaScript
Okay, das heißt, ich kann mich darauf verlassen, dass das erste immer das, das, das, das, der key ist oder was?
Okay, okay, alles klar
Okay, warum ist es jetzt in so einer bescheuerten Reihenfolge?
Ja, Objekt Entries gibt mir den Array zurück, aber über das Array loop ich das Item aus dem Array. Sollte eigentlich was Anderes sein?
Warum ist es jetzt eigentlich verkehrt herum? Warum ist das 30, 70, 38, 39, 30, 60? 30, 60 ist da oben. Ach so, weil das ist kein
Alter, was machst du da?
Ich will, dass das ein String ist, wobei, ne, das ist ein Objektkey, das ist eigentlich egal. Jetzt ist es richtig?
Jetzt ist es andersrum?
Was auch immer
Ich hinterfragt das jetzt nicht, warum das jetzt die Reihenfolge nicht beibehält. Okay, das ist jetzt nicht richtig.
Ich hinterfragt das jetzt nicht, warum das jetzt die Reihenfolge nicht beibehält. Okay
Alles klar
Ja gut, ein Dictionary ist ja auch normalerweise nicht sortiert. Das ist schon in Ordnung. Das gibt eigentlich keine Sprache, wo das, wo das sortiert ist, weil
außer es ist ein Sorted Dictionary, aber normalerweise ist das standardmäßig nicht sortiert, weil es ja eigentlich Sinn und Zweck der Sache ist, dass du da eben kein Index hast, also ergibt, ergibt schon, ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn.
Okay, aber das passt jetzt. Jetzt heißt, ich könnte jetzt, wenn ich meinen Shop umstelle, also meinen Crawler umstelle,
jetzt alle möglichen Status-Dinger anzeigen. Okay, jetzt muss ich natürlich hier noch einstellen, also Item.
Aber Item kann nicht Null sein. Ich muss jetzt gucken, if Item 1 gleich Null. Wenn Item 1 gleich Null,
Null. Keck wait. Alter JavaScript, ich checke ja nichts. Item. Item ist was? Ein Array. So, ein Array mit einem leeren Objekt.
So, ist das nicht Null oder was? Ist ein leeres Objekt, ist nicht Null. Okay, was ist denn ein leeres Objekt? Kann ich, kann ich so checken? Was zum Geier ist das?
Warum ist das nicht das? Mach doch vItem. Nein, vItem geht doch nicht. vItem ist ein Array, wo was drin ist. Aber ich kann checken,
ist größer 1. Ich kann checken, ob es größer 1 ist. Okay, item length größer 1.
Ist es length? 2? Ach nee, das ist ja immer, das ist ja immer größer. Hä? Was ist das wieder für ein Schwachsinn, Alter?
Okay, item, also item ist ein leeres Objekt. Ist es, was check ich denn dann überhaupt? Item, item 1. Kann ich, kann ich sowas machen? If item 1? If not item 1?
Item ist ein Array, aber item 1 ist kein Array. Hä? Und jetzt? If not item 1, ja wenn das nicht, wie check ich denn? Wie überprüfe ich das denn jetzt, ob das Null ist?
Muss ich jetzt sagen, muss ich jetzt sagen, wie war das mit Keys? Alter, Keys? Sowas? Hä? Das kann doch jetzt nicht in den Ernst sein, oder?
Ah, falsch rum, falsch rum. Ähm, wait a minute. Hä? Ach not. If, if, äh, äh, ja.
Ah ja, aha, okay. Okay, ich, ich behaupte nicht, dass ich verstehe, was passiert. Ich verstehe nicht, dass ich verstehe, was passiert, aber wir haben jetzt die Sachen drin stehen hier. Das ist schon mal, das ist schon mal nice.
Jetzt kann ich umstellen auf 30, 90, 38, 30, 70 noch. Schon mal, schon mal cool. So, probieren wir jetzt gleich mal aus. Jetzt kriegen wir nämlich anstatt, äh, schieb das mal. Jetzt kriegen wir nämlich, ich mach mir hier noch mal ein Terminal auf.
Äh, also anstatt, anstatt Dings, äh, 30, ups, hopp, hopp. So, das ist die ASUS-Karte. So, und jetzt kriegen wir nämlich eine 30, 70. Genau. So, 30, so, okay.
Jetzt kriegen wir eine 30, 70. Das heißt, Serious ist jetzt eine 30, 70. 30, 70. Ha! Nice. Es ist zwar hässlich wie die Nacht, aber das macht, was ich will.
Okay, jetzt können wir den Kram noch austauschen. Item. Bam, ba, ba, bam. Ja. 30, 70. So, das heißt, Item 1 ist dann das Object da unten drunter. Oder wie? Also, Item 1 muss ich da jetzt machen. Item 1.
Anstatt den ganzen Krämpel. Ups, bin ich jetzt rausgetappt. Das ist mega hässlicher Kram, den ich hier treibe.
Okay. Okay, das funktioniert immer noch. Immer noch. Pause Jam. Okay, und jetzt mache ich meinen Tracker auf eine 30, 70. Und dann sollte er das eigentlich auch, sollte er das eigentlich mitbekommen.
Probieren wir mal aus. Ah, meinen lokalen, meinen lokalen Tracker. Also, ähm, wo habe ich denn den? Hab ich den lokal, Moment, hatte ich den lokal installiert überhaupt?
Clone. Ja, cd repo, cd street merchant, da ist er. Also, jetzt müssen wir die Konfig mal kurz umkopieren. Pull, gibt noise.
Also, dot net, nf. Ähm, jetzt muss ich mal meine Konfig rüber kopieren. Ja, war Scripts unnötig kompliziert. Naja, gut, das, was ich jetzt mache, ist ja auch überhaupt nicht dafür gedacht gerade.
Ich wollte einfach gucken, ob ich das jetzt eingebaut kriege. Ehm, dot nf. Oh, kriege ich das rauskopiert? Wir haben einen, das kriegt 17. Bam, so. Easy copy, easy live.
Ähm, zack, zack, zack. Ups, kannst du mal. Okay. Jetzt haben wir die ganzen Müll mitkopiert. Also, amazon.de, asus, evga war deprecated, alles klar.
Das checkt er jetzt. So, und jetzt sagen wir ihm, er soll nicht noch, sondern er soll 30.70 checken, 30.80 und, und 30.90 soll er checken. Run. Start.
Okay, schauen wir mal. Hier kriegen wir jetzt zumindest eine Nachricht, wenn er was findet. Also, out of stock, out of stock. Ist denn irgendwo überhaupt eines davon lieferbar?
Werden wir gleich sehen. Out of stock, out of stock, alles out of stock. Warten wir mal, hachen wir mal da Dinge, bis was lieferbar ist. iChillX3 ist ausverkauft. Aha. Was ist, was ist es? 30.90. Fuck.
Warum ging das jetzt, warum geht das jetzt nicht? Was ist hier los? 30.70, 30.90 hat er doch erkannt. Warum hat er das hier nicht erkannt?
Ah, ich noob, weil ich nicht refreshed hab, null. Hätte ich mal refreshed, dann hätte es auch funktioniert.
Jetzt warten wir mal, bis der nächste, bis der nächste refresh kommt. Oder time out die Websocket Verbindung einfach zu schnell, aber der sollte doch normalerweise keep alive, oder?
Wow, wow, wow, wow. String ist null. MonkaS. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Das ist kaputt. Das ist kaputt, Leute. Warum? Was ist null? Komm mal, da hat es doch alle drinne.
Hä? Wow, wow, wow, wow. Wo ist das Problem?
Was? Wie kostet denn der Kram ein, steht nicht da.
Wo ist jetzt das Problem? Okay, wir machen mal, wir machen mal eine Debug-Ausgabe.
Block data. Jetzt warten wir mal, bis die nächste Grafikkarte reinkommt und dann, guck da, bäm, da sind wir schon. Object. Hä? Was ist das? Brand? Null. Created. Ah, brand ist... Wait a minute, was ist das?
Kek wait? Was?
Kek wait? Wie? Brand null bei alternate?
Kek wait? Ach, ich weiß warum. Oh, ich bin so bescheuert. Ich hab das doch lokal nicht gepatcht. Ich hab das doch, oh, man, ich hab das doch hier gepatcht, dass es funktioniert.
Notifications. MQTT. Siehste, das ist das Problem, wenn man das nur, wenn man das nur remote macht. Das da hab ich ja lokal gar nicht drinne. Ja, kein Wunder, dass der Kram nicht funktioniert.
So, stopp. Uh, source. Wo muss ich hin? Uh, notifications. So, message. Jetzt haben wir nicht den gleichen Fehler wie das letzte Mal. So, message. Jetzt muss man hier irgendwo sagen, jason stringify.
Jason stringify. Ja, jetzt funktioniert's auch gleich. Run.
So.
While. Ah. Ich hab den gestoppt. Uh,.net. Run.
So. Und jetzt sollte er das eigentlich gecheckt haben. Ah. Ah, ist noch nicht gestartet. Okay, gut. RiceChamp ist am Start. Was, can't establish connection? Wie? Da ist er doch.
Was ist das jetzt? Sag mal, heute ist es aber, heute hast du aber gar keinen Bock mehr. Ah, nee, jetzt geht's wieder. Okay. Guck mal, 3090 ist am Start. Für ganze 1799. Easy.
Da ist er. In stock. Funktioniert.
Ich kann noch einen Sort machen, ja. Stimmt, ich kann einen Sort machen.
So. Nice. Sehr gut. Warum sind da jetzt eigentlich so viele, so viele Breaks dazwischen? Weil ich so viele Breaks gemacht hab.
Jetzt müsste eventuell der Shop noch stimmen. Wieso? Der Shop stimmte doch. Mindfactory. Bäm. Stimmt doch. Alles gut.
Okay, Quaid. So, alles richtig. Nice. Das kann ich gleich auch noch pushen. Das kann ich auch gleich noch pushen rauf. Dann hat die Seite wenigstens halb irgendwie noch ein bisschen in Sitz.
Ja, stimmt doch. Alles. Sehr gut. Sehr schön. Fällt mir. Sehr gut.
Sehr gut. Guck mal, 109999. Easy. Da sind wir. Passt. Getrackt. Schön.
Ähm. Vielleicht soll. Wie konnte man in JavaScript nochmal die letzten zwei Zahlen abschneiden?
GS around two digits. Was machen die da?
Too fixed zwei. Okay. Too fixed zwei. Machen wir. Mein Gott ist das eklig ist zusammengewurstet hier. Guck mal, guck mal, funktioniert.
Link Alternate für Zotac 1889
Kannst du auch eine automatische Bestellung einbauen?
Nein, das geht nicht
Das ist zwar theoretisch machbar, aber da müsste ja quasi die Leute mir ihre Daten
geben und so
Die will ich gar nicht
So, cool
So, dann werde ich den Preischamp nochmal schnell hochschieben
Guck mal, Overclockers
Overclockers, verfügbar, nice, in stock, 10 Stück
Und wisst ihr was das coole ist, jetzt kann ich das sogar relativ easy
Ich erweitere jetzt die Anzeige hier nicht, weil das war eigentlich gar nicht dafür gedacht
Ich hab die Seite gebaut, dass ich ein Ding anzeigen kann, deswegen ist es ja auch so
eklig
Das baue ich noch ein mit mehreren Shops auf einmal und sowas
Aber die Seite ist dafür gemacht, eine Karte anzuzeigen aktuell
Ihr habt ja gesehen, wie eklig es war noch mehr einzubauen
Ok, Preischamp, zumal ja auch keine Notifications
So Chat, wo wir gerade dabei sind, wie macht man, wie macht man?
Chrome Desktop Notifications
Dass zumindest ein Popup kommt, das könnte man noch probieren
Dass zumindest ein Popup kommt, wenn es verfügbar ist
Weil ich muss mal kurz nebenbei was futtern
So mal gucken, wie geht denn das, Chrome?
Ich glaube, man kann kein Custom Sound machen, kann man Custom Sound machen?
Notifications, ok, ah hier
Notify, wir Copy Pasten das einfach mal von Mozilla gerade
Notify Send Notify
Check if the Browser supports Notifications Oh, was jetzt?
Ah, ich hab den Links vergessen
Jaja, ich brauch die ganzen, wer braucht Comments, Alter?
Comments für Noobs Browser does not support Desktop Notifications
Wir gehen einfach mal von aus, der kann das oder?
Es kann doch, naja gut Ja, nicht unbedingt
Apple, iOS kann es natürlich nicht, ne Notification Request Permission
Das muss ich ganz am Anfang von der App machen
Das muss ich ganz am Anfang beim Starten machen
Dass der mich nach Permissions fragt
If Notifications Denied, dann, ups
Oh, Monks, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
If, warte mal, es ist ja auch Mounted If Mounted, Permissions is Denied, dann Request
Permission Ok, das restliche brauchen wir eigentlich
gar nicht
Der sollte mich jetzt fragen, dass ich ihm Desktop Notifications schicken darf, oder?
Ah, hier, will you allow to send Notifications?
Ja
Ok, dann können wir nämlich das hier raus machen
If, kann man nämlich einfach schauen
Das ist granted
Elseif, genau, das andere brauchen wir hier gar nicht
So
Warum macht denn das Elseif da oben auf die Zeile, das sieht da
Äh, hallo, äh, hä, was haben sie sich denn hier ausgedacht?
Kann ich nicht einfach sagen, if das da und das da und das einfach oben weglassen?
Oh, Mist, Else, ja
Ok
So, also das heißt, er sollte mir jetzt eine Notification schicken
Ok, wir probieren jetzt mal aus, ob das prinzipiell funktioniert
Send Notification
Text CACW Notification, ok
Ach ne, meinst du auch
Send Notify this
Ah, guck mal, die Notification kommen raus
Kann man, jetzt müsste man nur noch in Firefox einbauen, dass man eine Custom Sound bekommt
Ok, Send Notification, wir senden eine Notification, wenn
Jedes Mal, wenn hier was reinkommt, ne, easy
Und zwar mit Snapshot Serious, einfach nur verfügbar
So, also sprich, sobald jetzt was verfügbar wird, sollte ich einen Popup kriegen
Ach so, ja, wie gesagt, man kann es ja auch noch nicht filtern oder so
Wobei man könnte, man könnte jetzt sagen, ok, ich mache ein Häkchen dran, was ich Notified
werden will
Aber erstmal gucken, ob das Notify funktioniert
Bäm
Punched
Allerdings lasse ich das jetzt erstmal, nein, der Web Scraper ist nicht von mir selbst
Ich wollte am Anfang den selbst bauen, aber ich hab mir gedacht, ich bleib da im Leben
nicht up to date
Guckt, sogar wenn ich den Desktop wechsle, krieg ich jetzt Notifications
Dass einfach irgendwo aufmachen und gut ist
Natürlich ist das nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss, weil, ich reloade mal, man kann ja
aktuell
Da war eine 3070, ja, habt ihr das gesehen Leute, wo war's
Street Merchant auf GitHub suchen
Ich mach das mit den Notifications jetzt mal raus, weil, sonst werdet ihr ja zugespammt
mit Notifications, falls ihr auf die Seite geht
Also, ich werd das dann auf jeden Fall so machen, dass man da ein Häkchen dran machen
kann, wo man Notified werden will
Die Seite werd ich eh ein bisschen anders gestalten, ich hab mir das so gedacht, ich
mach einfach so eine Übersichtssite, wo man eintragen kann, was man haben will
Und, ähm, ab welchem Preis man es haben will, weil vielleicht will man es nicht für 2000
Euro kaufen
Und dann kriegt man einfach ein Dashboard, wo man das alles sieht, weil aktuell ist ja
der Spam viel zu groß
Aber ich werd das mal raufschieben, ohne die Notifications wohlgemerkt
Äh, ohne die Notifications
Weil sonst spamm ich euch voll
Okay, History, jaja, deswegen speicher ich mit das Lokal den Datenbank
Das war eigentlich der ursprüngliche Gedanke dahinter, weil ich eine Preishistory machen
wollte
So, und jetzt wisst ihr, was das cool ist, wir können jetzt auch total easy noch Ryzen
einbauen
Pass mal auf, wir können total easy noch Rützen können wir einbauen
Ähm, und zwar machen wir hier aus
CD, Source, Store, Model, wir müssen nur mal kurz gucken, wie der Kram heißt
Crap, Ryzen, so, Serious, Ryzen 5600, 5800, 5900, da haben wir es doch alles
Okay, 7 gibt's nicht, Ryzen 5
Genau, die können wir auch noch einbauen
Die Fall-View-Icon, ich hatte heute andere Probleme
Wir können das die Fall-View-Icon ändern, wenn ihr wollt
Jemand hat eine glorreiche Idee, wir machen eins von, wir machen das Whoop-Pok
Woop-Pok, das Emote machen wir zu einem, zu einem, äh, Favorite-Icon
Wir nehmen Whoop-Pok, dot, enf, okay Serious, was brauche ich jetzt noch, also
Ryzen, man merkt auch, dass der Typ das Projekt angefangen hat mit Grafikkarten im Kopf und
es dann nachher erweitert hat, weil die Benamung, da wird er auf jeden Fall Probleme bekommen
später
Weil er die nicht schon hat, weil er muss darauf achten, dass die Serious Unix sind,
wenn die Serious nicht mal Unix sind, funktioniert der ganze Scheiß nicht
Und sollte mal AMD eine Grafikkarte haben, die auch 3090 heißt, muss das AMD 3090 nennen,
sonst funktioniert's nicht mehr
So, auf welche Webseite, du musst, äh, beta.preisjam.org, allerdings da ist noch die Version von vor
einer Stunde noch nicht, die die mehr kann
Die werde ich aber gleich hinschieben, jetzt machen wir erstmal noch die, die AMD-CPUs
rein
Okay, und jetzt brauchen wir hier, äh, Serious, wie hießen die Dinger, das hab ich schon
wieder vergessen
Hier Serious Ryzen
Zack, zack, so ne, ups
Also was war es, 8000, 9000, äh, 5000, 9000, 5500, okay, zack
Und nun, okay, der listet schon mal auf, schon mal nice
Äh, und jetzt können wir sagen, einfach starten, häh, run, ups, äh, run, npm, start run
Äh, 6800, können wir auch nehmen, 6, müssen wir noch mal kurz, ja, können wir gleich machen,
ähm, so ne Frage, wie der Kram heißt, ne, oma street, äh, es heißt, 8000, ach guck mal,
dann werden wir da, ja, ohne Scheiß, jetzt können wir alles dabei machen, die, die, die
drei Sachen mehr, die machen sie jetzt auch nicht aus, oder, jetzt können wir einfach
alles dabei machen
So, also, Ryzen, Rx, 6800, Rx, 6680 XT, äh, Sony PS5C, Sony PS5DE, Xbox, wer will ne
Xbox, lul, X, also früher war ich ja Xbox-Fan, und da haben mir die Playstation-Fanboys immer
die Xbox geflamet und gesagt, das ist die Wixbox, mittlerweile muss ich sagen, nachdem
mir die, die haben mich komplett verloren mit den letzten paar Xboxen, Leute, ihr habt
mitgeguckt, dass ich mich nicht verschrieben hab, hoffe ich, hab ich vergessen, echt,
ah, Rx, 6000, äh, XT ist das, ne, oder, ja, ok, gut, run, schau ma ma, äh, ach so, ha,
ich noob, Moment, das muss ich ja noch in die Webseite eintragen, also, warum ist das
eigentlich gequotet und das andere nicht, hä, muss ich das jetzt verstehen, also das
haben wir alles schon, flop, Rx, XT, Sony, ey, guck ma, hab ich gut gezählt oder gut
gezählt, hä, ok, Mine Factory in stock, bam, Funst, jetzt wird's langsam ein bisschen
viel für eine Seite, ne, aber ist egal, für heute, für heute haben wir da wirklich unsere
Arbeit getan, ja, guck ma, hier, 6800, Mine Factory, da, dann, größer 5, ja, ja,
ja, ja, das muss ich auf jeden Fall, ich wollte das eigentlich so machen, dass man auf der
Übersicht ankreuzen kann, CPU, GPU, also gleich schon auf der Übersicht, AMD, GPU, Nvidia
GPU, äh, AMD, CPU, oder, äh, Xbox oder Playstation, da kommt man auf eine Seite, wo ein bisschen
weniger drauf steht, ja, aber der Preischamp champt schon mal, so, GenerateFufIcon, Favico.io,
genau, PNG to Eco, alles klar, das brauchen wir, Track and Drop, Upload, ähm, Repos, Repos,
Aschamp, Client App, Alter, wo hab ich Source, Assets, wo POC, jawoll, da ist es, exquisite,
kann ich das nämlich hier reinträgen und droppen, ähm, wo macht man das überhaupt
hin, das Favicon, das kommt schon in Assets rein, oder, denk ich mal, UFicon, Static,
was, Public, ja, wo denn nur, ah, hier, Public kommt's rein, alles einfach, ich geh mal davon
aus, die Dinger müssen so heißen, äh, ernsthaft, kann ich das nur einfach, Track and Dropen,
ich kann das gar nicht Track and Dropen, CacWade, warum nicht, ok, Extract Files, nach Temp,
ja wunderbar, wollte schon immer mal nach Temp, ähm, jetzt muss man da rum, jetzt muss
man da auch noch rumdingsen, ja, Temp, wo sind sie, hier, oh, das war keine gute Idee,
ich muss nach Temp zu, was ist das, Side Manifest, oh, CacWade, der ist abgeschissen, äh, Felix,
oder auch nicht, what the, fuck, Alter, das vorbei, oh, das ist RIP, Xkill, ja, ne, hab
ich, ich hab das net installiert, echt net, Xkill, nein, kann ichs jetzt bedienen, yes,
Xkill, zack, bam, piss dich, Alter, ja, kopieren wirs jetzt von Hand, äh, wo hab ich den Download
gehabt, siehst du mal, dass so einfache Dinger manchmal so sinnlos kompliziert sind, ich
glaube, Extracted ist jetzt einfach ein richtiger Ordner, ok, ähm, Home, Repos, Preischamp,
Client App, Source, ne, Public, Public, bam, Extract, Thomas, na, oh Gott, oh, please,
die machen wir echt ins Leben schwer, äh, Public, yes, Replays, yes, hä, CacWade,
ah, hier, Base, ok, haben wirs jetzt geschafft, endlich, haben wirs jetzt endlich geschafft,
da ist er, excellent, ja, neues Favicon Icon, wo ist der Preis, der Preis, der steht da,
wenn er was findet, was hat er gefunden, 3080, 3090, komm mal, unten, unten, unten Rützen
hat er, bam, guck mal hier, Farmine Factory, Ryzen, ein paar Overclockers, das funktioniert,
Winch grad gedacht, dass das so easy ist, ok, sehr schön, dann, hups, jetzt hab ich
zugemacht, aber das passt schon, dann werd ich das mal deployen, dass ihrs ausprobieren
könnt, vorher brauchen wir die.env, die Series, muss ich mir kopieren, dass die auf der Cloud
auch am Start sind, das muss ich ausmachen, das kann ich ausmachen, könnt ihrs gleich
schon mal ausprobieren, sehen wir mal aus, machen wir auch aus,.env, Series, hallo, hopp,
ich glaub, die Shops reichen doch auch erstmal, oder, amazon.de,.evga, mal mal raus, das
sind doch so die, das sind doch so eigentlich die wichtigsten, oder, oder soll ich mal wirklich
alle reinmachen, ich mein, ich kann auch mal alle reinmachen, geil wäre, wenn die Webapp
den Crawler von selbst aktualisieren könnte, das muss die Webapp nicht machen, das ist
relativ simpel, da muss ich nen Customs Script basteln, weil das Ding hat ne API, wo man abfragen
kann, was es unterstützt wird, da müsste ichs aber wahrscheinlich besser in den Docker
Containers packen, da kann ich das nämlich regelmäßig updaten, gucken, das ist auf
jeden Fall drin, ok, jetzt haben wir mal alles am Start hier, da fehlen jetzt aber manche
Sachen, also was machen, was machen wir jetzt noch dabei von den da oben, AMD können wir
dabei machen, Asus,.de, Arlt, Caseking haben wir, Computer Universe haben wir auch, Cyberport
meinetwegen, Equipper, Expert, also FuturX und Galaxus, kennt das jemand, hab ich noch
nie gehört, Gamestop ist Gamas Job, den unterstützen wir nicht, Mediamarkt haben wir schon, Medimax
hab ich glaub ich auch noch nie was gekauft, taugt das, Export, Expert, Otto, PC King,
Staturen, Staturen haben wir schon, Spielegrotte müssen wir glaub ich net gucken, können wir
aber machen das, weil es ne gute Seite ist, als gibts den Pro Shop, gibts auch noch, alles
klar, ok, dann hauen wir mal rein, Notebooks billiger haben wir schon oder, haben wir die
schon nicht, ne haben wir nicht, so und jetzt SCPen wir das rüber, Release, jawoll, ach
ne Moment, CD, Client, App, Build, erstmal die Web App bilden, dass das dann auch funktioniert,
da machen wir den Crawl an der Maus, dass ich das auch gleich alles mitkriege ob es funktioniert,
ok, ok, kopier den Preischamp rüber, gibs uns, exellent Preischamp, auf auf, übrigens
nice, für Leute am Start sind, Poggers, ja finde ich auch, SCP Beste, also mir schwebt
vor, dass ich das dann später über GitHub Actions mach und SCP auch größer R-Sync,
denn R-Sync wird ja schneller gehen und schneller ist weniger Geld, solange mir pro Stunden
bezahlt wird, du kannst gleich Preischampen sobald es da ist, ok, schauen wir mal, betabeta.preischamp.org,
da sind wir, wir müssen nur noch warten bis mal was verfügbar wird, ich teste mal kurz
ob es funktioniert, Pupp, ok klappt, der Kekweshop, du schaust eine Stunde zu, ist doch nice,
Spielecord ist out of stock, kills Batman, übrigens der Surfer ist viel zu schwach,
das Ding ist permanent am Anschlag rein mit Crawlen, das heißt das packt vielleicht noch
irgendwie 10 User zusätzlich oder so, also, so, schauen wir mal ob alles funktioniert,
Leute, ihr könnt ja mal mitgucken ob jetzt grün wird, also ich sage euch wo es grün
werden müsste, gucken wir mal, oh, kann es sein das es abkackt, weil es überlastet
ist, oh, also wir haben einen, da, bam, Ryzen 5600, noch mehr Ryzens, ja das sind auch 5600,
ne, 5800, Leute ist bei euch der 5800 da grün geworden, ich glaube der Surfer ist überlastet,
ich glaube der Surfer ist überlastet, ich glaube der Surfer ist überlastet, rollt er
für jeden User einzeln, ne, oh Leute, das kackt voll ab, das ist der Surfer ist überlastet,
das kommt nicht an, so jetzt haben wir 3090, das funktioniert, aber wenn zu viel gleichzeitig
kommt klappt es nicht, wenn zu viel gleichzeitig kommt dann funktioniert es nicht, guck mal
der Time outet auch übelst, ich glaube der crawlt jeden Job einzeln, ok, 5800, ja, guck
mal, das ist Serverüberlastung, das ist Serverüberlastung, jemand der gesagt hat das braucht dringenden
Crit, der kann gerne am Frontend mitbasteln, ja, nice, ok, gut, wieso kommen und gehen
die Angebote, weil das absolut kein State Management aktuell hat, ich schreibe mir das
zwar lokal in die Datenbank rein, aber das wird noch null ausgewertet, also wenn du
nicht mit deinem Browser auf der Seite bist, während die Info kommt, ist da, steht da
nicht verfügbar, ich schreibe es mir aber lokal in die Datenbank, dass ich das quasi
machen kann, ich schreibe mir die letzten Sachen in die Datenbank, dann kann ich die
immer wieder ausliefern, 6800 ist grün, ich habe aber jetzt halt bis das, der Link sollte
im neuen Tab aufgehen, das ist eine gute Idee, ja, ja, da hast du recht, das, das, das stimmt,
wo ist denn der Link, ich bin nicht mehr durch bei meinem Zeug, da, wie ging das nochmal
mit dem neuen Tab, Target ne, Target und dann, oh fuck, Link, Target, New Tab, Link, wirklich,
ok, 39 in Stock Leute, der Playstation ist nicht verfügbar, kann das sein, ey, der Server
kackt übelst ab, ist das so, dass gerade keine Xboxen und Playstation verfügbar sind, ok,
Leute, ich glaube wir müssen upgraden, ja, weniger Abfragen machen, ich würde gerne
weniger Abfragen machen, das Problem ist, ich weiß nicht, wie man den Kram genau konfiguriert,
es gibt, guck mal, es gibt, es gibt zwar die Option, es gibt zwar die Option, Page, whoops,
ohje, was hab ich jetzt gemacht, erstmal schließen, Page, Page Backoff, Page Sleepman, so, da
könnte ich das machen, aber das ändert nichts da dran, wie viel der parallel macht, der
macht alle Shops glaube ich parallel, Commerce Separate can include Page Sleep, was macht
er eigentlich bei mir lokal, ich mein, lokal hab ich ja genug, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
wie viel CPU last, so mal zum gucken, wie viel CPU last macht er eigentlich bei mir
lokal, ich mein, lokal hab ich ja genug, hm, Epos, Street, Run, bin ich mal gespannt, noch
gehts ja nicht los, oh, oh, oh shit, ok, Server Upgrading wird nichts bringen, das sind 8,
das sind Übertragte der 8700K, da gibt es eigentlich nur eins, das Ding muss in den
Docker Container, das muss in den Docker Container und CPU Limit drauf, sonst ist nichts mehr
für die Seite übrig, das mach ich heute aber nicht mehr, zeig euch gleich, ich schreiß
ja mal aus, kann man ohne Docker Container, Unterlinung ist auch schon, CPU Limit Application,
achja, genau, CPU Limit, nein, Kuba, nee, das, nee, ich wollte es dir erzählen, Low-Up-Task-CPU-Limit,
das hab ich schon nie ausprobiert, CPU Limit, wie macht man das, normal an 80, alles klar,
ah, das kann man eben nachhinein machen, ok, das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, nee, also
wenn ich das machen würde, dann würde ich einen zweiten Server mieten, der mir die Sachen
einliefert auf dem ersten, Up-Search-CPU-Limit, nice, Up-Install-CPU-Limit, dann probieren
wir das doch jetzt mal aus, by the way, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet überhaupt? Falsch,
muss hier hin, ups, dahin, jetzt müsste schon fast alles eigentlich, oh nee, ich hab den
Preis-Champ nicht mehr auf, Leute, ah, jetzt müsste mittlerweile fast alles grün sein
im Preis-Champ, also, probieren wir mal aus, CPU-Limit, ok, also, PS AUX-Grab, wie hieß
dieses Ding, Street, nee, Node, nach Node muss ich gucken, oh, ich kann das nicht CPU-Limiten,
weil da 50 Milliarden Prozessor aufmacht, ok, das muss in den Docker-Container rein,
sonst wird das nix, can't wait, kann ich nicht limiten, ich glaube, das mit Kubernetes meinte
der Chat auch nicht ernst, das kommt in den Container rein, CPU-Limit, gut ist, aber ich
lass jetzt erstmal laufen, der ist ja erstmal gut beschäftigt jetzt, was war der Grund
nochmal, warum ich den Docker-Container gemacht hab gleich, der Grund war, ah, weil die Ubuntu
Firewall mit Docker-Container rumspackt, genau, aber der Timeout ist halt, auf der anderen
Seite eigentlich ist das mit dem Timeout ja gar nicht so wild, ok, ich versuch mal, ich
versuch mal, Settings zu machen, also, ah, man kann mehrere Proxys angeben, da kann ich
das verteilen, also, page back of min, Minimum back of time between retrying requests for
the same store when a forbidden response, ok, das ist erstmal page sleep, page sleep min,
machen wir mal hoch auf, komm, es reicht doch alle 30 Sekunden, oder, oder jede Minute,
jede Minute reicht doch eigentlich, wir wollen es ja mal nicht übertreiben, win, page, also,
der sleep mindestens 60, also mindestens eine Minute und maximal, wenn es wieder dran kommen
muss, ist keine Ahnung, zwei Minuten, ist das was ich da eingegeben hab, das sollte doch
ein bisschen CPU-Last rausnehmen, wahrscheinlich müssen wir jetzt eine Minute warten, bis das
anfängt was zu machen, welche Linux, das ist Manjaro mit i3-WM, ah ja, und diese exceptions
da oben sind übrigens vollkommen normal, das ist auch bei denen im GitHub drin, immer
wenn eine Connection timeoutet, dann schmeißt das so ein Ding, ist natürlich geil fürs
Log, da findet man die richtigen Fehler nicht, der müsste, der müsste die alte Nagios-Taktik
machen, einfach nicht alle bei Null starten, sondern schon den ersten Check verteilt ausführen,
by the way, und was wir in die Seite auch noch einbauen müssen, ist ein retry, nenn ich retry,
reconnect, Websockets, das soll das zwar eigentlich automatisch machen, aber man weiß ja nie,
ok guckt, jetzt braucht der eine Minute bis es anfängt, dann fängt er mit allen Seiten
gleichzeitig an, ach ja, das mit Euro krieg ich nicht raus, Dragon Fight, ich krieg nur
einen Preisbetrag ohne Currency, also ich gehe einfach davon aus, es sind Euro, weil
ich normalerweise nur EU-Shops drin hab, was für ein Shop ist denn auf Englisch, welcher
Shop ist denn das, der is UK, Overclockers, ja gut, kann man mitleben, ist doch nicht
mal mehr EU, ja und die hatten ja auch nie Euro, aber ich glaube jetzt ist es ein bisschen
weniger CPU-Laster, ja, nein, ja, nein, ok das kann sein, dass es am Anfang einfach
ein bisschen braucht, bis der alles einmal abgecrawlt hat, ich mein wir könnten auch
mal ganz hart sein und sagen, einfach nur mal weil es geht, wir können uns aber 16
CPU Kerne gönnen, wir können wieder downscalen, wollen wir das mal ausprobieren, wie es mit
16 CPU Kerne ist, let's go, ok, machen wir, guck mal, der kann sich ja kaum noch beenden,
Power off, ok, ja da brauchen wir ein paar Prime Subs, da kann ich mir das leisten, sonst
kann ich morgen nichts mehr essen, übrigens danke für alle die heute gesappt haben, ich
hab glaub ich kaum reingeguckt, ich guck noch mal kurz schnell, wir machen bevor Stream
fertig, jetzt noch mal ne Runde Subraten, wieviel's jetzt sind, aber jetzt nicht, also
TKsgoodlife hat abonniert, Dankeschön, vor zwei Stunden hab ich nicht gesehen, Chefsessl
noch, vor zwei Stunden schon, zwei Monate, Dankeschön, so, wen haben wir da sonst noch,
xFatal, Dankeschön, vor drei Stunden schon, wie lang bin ich, wie lang bin ich on, Donations,
nee, Donations hatte ich drinnen und dann ist Tippy Stream abgekackt und ich hab mir
gedacht, nee, scheiß drauf, ok, Rescaled, Leute, jetzt wird Rescaled, Rescaled, Bäm,
wir rescalen jetzt auf 16 CPU Kerne, rescale, äh, Reed, vier Monate, Dankeschön für
den Sub, jetzt übertreibt man nicht, Alter, jetzt kommt gleich das Scam Train auch noch,
vermute ich mal bei so vielen Subs, gddyco, Dankeschön für den Prime Sub und dann Reed
noch mal mit 10 Stufe 1 Abos, der Chat IQ geht ja durch die Decke, ja Dankeschön hier
noch mal, für extra 10 Abos, das ist ja richtig, der hat halt was gekriegt, Picotel Tide, Morris,
Yoykel, Muffin Cody, Corino, Rakors, Jazz Hammer, Cheese Hunter, Ophirix, ach du Scheiße,
weiß nicht ob ich das richtig ausgesprochen hab, Essplune, TP Tux, Massive Subscriptions
hier wieder, sehr nice, Ende 1337, zwei Monate, Dankeschön für den Sub, der Chat IQ Kopf
muss ja gleich platzen, so was sagt es, rescalen, ok, er rescaled noch, er rescaled noch, guck
mal, das Scam Train ist gleich auf Level 4, Instant Scam Level 4, einfach too smart, der
Kopf platzt, way too smart, das können sich alle hinsetzen mit dem dicken Kopf und Rotwein
verkosten und dann, ah yes, exquisite Geschmack, so hat er gescaled, ist er fertig, easy 60
Euro im Monat, komm, Scheiß drauf, Endprog, 16 Kerne, jawoll, so ist das gut, ja so mag
ich das, der Server laggt, guck mal hier, wenn ich Enter drücke, ich hab die Verbindung
gerade für den Server verloren, der hat zu viel gescaled, glaub war zu viel des guten
Scaling, hat sich ausgescaled, guck mal, nicht mehr erreichbar, kaputt gescaled, kaputt
gescaled hat er sich, wie Reboot, das Ding ist gerade erst gestartet, guck hier, oh
jetzt geht, jetzt geht, what the fuck, Hetzner, Hetzner, was los mit euch, Chat, wer dedost
von euch jetzt wieder hier, Anzeige ist instant raus, I'm in, XenP, Dankeschön für den
Sub, ZF Chris, 3 Monate, huge subscriptions, Hetzner, was ist los, guckt euch mal an, das
ist voll am abscheißen, wieviel Traffic haben wir eigentlich noch keinen verbraucht, ok,
also ich bin geneigt dazu, ich würd sagen, ich mach ja noch mal Power off und mach wieder
Power on, man weiß ja nie, vollen ESX gekriegt, ja wahrscheinlich, what, Cacquade, ich hab
doch nicht auf 16 Kerne gescaled, dass es jetzt langsamer ist als vorher, in welchem
RZ bin ich denn jetzt, Nuremberg natürlich, what the fuck, ja gut dann scale ich jetzt
wieder runter, ok rescale, dann scalen wir jetzt eben auf 8 Kerne, geht nix hier, ja
das andere geht noch schnell, na gut, dann wird Downscaled wieder, auf 8, also das 16
Kerne war jetzt nicht so ne gute Idee, mehr Kerne weniger Bandbreite, aber mehr Kerne
auch mehr Geld, warum, warum, nee das scale muss ich nicht bezahlen, ich muss nur den
höheren Stundensatz für die Kiste bezahlen dann, der ist schon wieder da, ach Moment,
das ist der DNS 0w, auf scale, schneller Hetzner, scale scale scale, KLS skaliert auch immer,
die ganzen Scam Coaches skalieren, ich hab mir jetzt immer ein bisschen im Internet so,
just for fun, so ein paar dieser Coaching Videos angeguckt, die sind teilweise so unglaublich
dämlich ja, und was die teilweise für einen Stumpf sind erzählen, der eine Typ, hab ich
euch gesehen, der sagt man soll zu Fiverr gehen, jetzt kein Witz, ernsthafte Geschäftsmodell,
du sollst zu Fiverr gehen, und natürlich ziehen sie das so auf, so nach dem Motto, ich verrate
euch jetzt wie ihr mit 5 Stunden Arbeitseinsatz 10.000 Euro im Monat macht, von zu Hause,
ganz einfach, ja ihr kennt ja den Schluss, und der eine hat die Idee, ok jetzt gehts
wieder, jetzt haben wir gut gescaled, und der eine hat ernsthaft erzählt, man soll zu
Fiverr gehen, dort nen Chinese beauftragen, für ein E-Book zu schreiben, für keine Ahnung
15 Euro, und das E-Book publish man dann bei Amazon, was ist das für ne bescheuerte Idee,
das kauft doch keine Sau, random China E-Book, das geht wieder hoch, guck mal, da stimmt
doch was nett, sind die DDoS Champs wieder raus hier, ne der Umzug ist fertig,
Lizard Squad am Start, ey was ist das denn, es kann doch nicht sein, dass es danach einfach
nicht mal funktioniert, ok N-Proc, guckt euch das mal an, das stimmt doch ebenfalls nett,
oder es ist Unity Media, aber wenn es Unity Media wäre, dann würde man das ja auch sehen,
guckt euch mal an, übelst am abscheißen, also eine Sache, dass es eigentlich keiner
von euch sein kann ist, dass es plötzlich nach Rescaling gekommen ist, das ist schon
höchst verdächtig, ne ey ich will, kann man das RZ wechseln, kann man das RZ wechseln,
ich will Rescaling, ein anderes RZ, DMS wenigstens W weiß ich jetzt nicht, Timestamps, ne, Alter,
ach ne W ist Listen, genau, ok wir starten den Kram jetzt trotzdem mal neu, su- poggers,
ach ich bin schon poggers, ok ähm, Street, Run, guck mal mal wie viel Auslastung wir
haben, wir haben jetzt immerhin 8 Kerne, ja, das sieht doch schon besser aus, ok, ok, ok,
nicht safety, was denn, das ist das Wichtige das wir hier waren, ok, ok, ja, das sieht
Ihr seht ja auch wie lange die Pings hängen zwischendurch.
Ja und witzigerweise andere Dinger sind halt äh andere Dinger gar kein Problem, ja easy.
Wo ist gerade das Problem, dass der Surf Alarm ist, nachdem ich rescaled hab.
Der fängt gar nicht an jetzt.
Hab ich nicht Hetzner an sich gerade irgendwie Probleme, aber an sich geht eigentlich.
Guck mal hier, jetzt, jetzt will er's wissen.
Alter der macht 8 CPU Kerne voll.
Serious?
Wirklich?
Aber guck mal, guck mal seht ihr wie schnell das jetzt geht, seht ihr wie das flutscht,
seht ihr wie das durchflutscht jetzt.
Das hab ich nicht programmiert, das ist gar nicht von mir.
Jetzt flutscht's, so, oh guck mal, oh guck mal der Surfer geht wieder, DDoS Chat ihr
habt den DDoS ausgemacht, äh CD, Publish,.net, ok der Preischamp läuft wieder, Leute
der Preischamp ist wieder da, ach was denn das, ach ich hab noch die Debug Ausgabe drin,
ich kann noob, der Preischamp läuft wieder, bam, bearrlt, gibts was, nice, ok, ok, ok,
ihr macht ne Idee wie ich da easy, wie ich den easy, Leute ihr seid doch die krassen
CSS Pros, ne, wie mach ich hier nen easy crit draus, also quasi so dass er das auffüllt,
Hey Cortana!
Gar nicht. Oh, feelsBatman.
Aber guck mal, wie der jetzt flutscht, ey.
Und ich glaube, der geht jetzt auch ein bisschen runter, weil ich die Backup-Time hochgestellt hab.
...
Ne ne ne, ist kein Bootstrap, es ist Beautify.
Ähm. Ich würde halt einfach gerne, indem ich jetzt gar nichts großartig ändere, einfach nur Crit auffüllen oder so.
Wieso ist das Ding so am schmitzen?
Weil da gerade, keine Ahnung, 80 Chromium-Instanzen oder so laufen.
Guck mal.
Das ist alles Chromium.
Das sind 80 Chroms oder sowas.
Jetzt hat sich übrigens das, das auch erledigt und ich kann jetzt wieder normal pingen und das funktioniert auch.
Seht ihr?
Aber ich glaube, jetzt hat er sich ein bisschen eingekriegt und geht nicht mehr so hoch.
Ja, seht ihr? Jetzt ist er einmal durch, jetzt ist er einmal durch und jetzt greift er, jetzt greift das Backup-Ding.
Excellent, excellent.
Äh, Curl bringt nichts, weil manche Seiten haben lustige Cloudflare-Protections und sonstige Dinger.
Die wollen nicht gecrawled werden.
Deswegen ist es sinnvoller, das mit dem Chrome zu machen.
Das sieht halt nach echtem User aus.
Ja, ja ja, Scheiterhaufen aus Money.
Der ist, die Webseite war gar nicht dafür gedacht, so viel drauf zu machen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal testen, ob es mit einer 3060 TI geht.
Und der Chat hat mich gebadet weiterzubasteln.
Der hat absolut keine Logik drinne.
Ich hab zwar lokal eine History, ich hab lokal eine Datenbank mit History, aber die verwende ich noch gar nicht.
Und aktuell überschreibt der eiskalt immer den letzten Wert.
Das könnte man machen, aber da müsste ich das umprogrammieren und ich hab keinen Bock drauf.
Ich hab diesen Crawler nicht gebastelt.
Ich hab nur das Webinterface gebastelt und die Sachen drum herum.
Ich will da eigentlich gar nicht so viel dran machen, weil ich will einfach Git pullen und ich hab die neuesten Sachen, die gecrawled werden.
Was wollte ich jetzt nachgucken, Chat?
Mist, das vergessen.
Ich wollte irgendwas nachgucken.
Ah, die Datenbank, wie groß die ist.
Na ja, da tut sich nicht viel. Mal gucken, wie groß das morgen ist.
Crit, ja Serious Max mit dem Crit.
Wenn du mir sagst, wie ich das machen kann, dann mach ich das.
Leute, es geht wieder los.
Dedos ist raus wieder.
Botnets musste neu gestartet werden.
Botnets muss neu gestartet werden.
Diftrum mit CSS-Crit.
Okay, Auskernfunk. Exzellent Idee.
Ich hab zwar keine Ahnung.
Mal gucken, ob der sich wieder anzieht.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Okay, Auskernfunk. Exzellent Idee.
Mal gucken, ob der sich wieder einkriegt mit der Zeit.
Also, wie meinste?
Zeig mal.
Also, es ist eh schon nicht schön, was ich hier gebaut hab.
Also, ich mach hier ne Schleife, da hab ich ja schon nen Diff.
Ich mach nen Diff für jede Kategorie.
Also, das ist nen Diff.
So.
Und du meinst, ich mach da jetzt noch nen Diff drum?
Auch nen extra Diff?
Und dann?
Sag ich was? Style?
Display?
Crit?
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal, was du sagst.
Und dann gucken wir mal, was funktioniert.
So.
Ich muss ja erst mal starten, ob das funktioniert.
Ach guck mal.
Botnetz war nicht erfolgreich.
Botnetz wurde geblockt.
Okay, probieren wirs mal kurz aus.
Lokal.
Äh, äh, ähm.
Der Preischamp.
Surf.
Depots. Preischamp.
Okay.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir mal, was der Auskernfuchs da geschrieben hat.
Das ist das richtige CSS-Hackerman.
Der war schon ein paar Mal im Stream und hat so die Dinger aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt.
Das ist schon mal ziemlich gut.
Soll ich jetzt sagen, das ist schon mal ziemlich nice.
Das ist schon mal ziemlich nice.
Jetzt machen wir nur noch nen Margin oder sowas drum.
Class.
M.A.
2 oder so.
Poggers.
Hä?
Das ist doch mal was.
By the way, warum ist bei Asus, äh, die Uhrzeit irgendwie, hä?
Okay, Asus hat, das weiß nicht, was es tut.
Äh, das Crit, das Crit bewegt sich.
Warum bewegt sich, kann man ne feste Breite einstellen oder so?
Das Crit, das Crit zuggelt rum.
Kann man irgendwie ne feste Breite pro Links einstellen?
Aber es ist schon mal besser als vorher, ne?
Wenn jetzt zum Beispiel in 3.702 Shops ist, dann gewinnt der letzte Shop, der der aktuelle ist.
Siehste ja, überschreibt immer.
Da ist noch absolut keine Logik dahinter.
Das zeigt einfach nur stumpf an.
Was ist eigentlich ein FR?
Was, was bedeutet das?
Repeat?
Geh ich, ja?
Es ist, äh, vier Rows oder so?
Ne, vier Columns, eine Fraction.
Ah, das ist wie Breits ist, oder wie?
Wenn ich jetzt zwei Fractions mach, dann ändert sich auch nix.
Ah, kann ich, kann ich hier auch sowas sagen wie 50 Pixel oder so?
Ah, 200 Pixel.
Ah ja, ok, schon mal besser.
Ja, aber dann siehts kacke aus.
Ha, she baited.
Dann siehts, dann siehts kacke aus.
Dann, dann hängt das.
Aber dafür, dafür zappelt's, dafür zappelt's nicht rum.
25%?
Ja, das geht auch.
Warum FR und nicht Prozent?
Warum hat der beim Asus keinen Break drinne jetzt?
By the way, die 3080 Ti ist übelst verbugt, ne?
Die sollte man vielleicht besser raus machen.
Aber ich find's schon mal echt cool.
Ähm, warum hat denn der keinen Break da drinne?
Das ist zwischen, zwischen hat, da ist doch, da ist doch ein fettes Break drin.
Warum breakt der hier nicht?
Asus, please?
What?
Warum macht der da keinen Break? Der ist doch eins.
Hallo?
Ah, jetzt ist weg.
Ah, she baited.
Ach, Moment, das ist da gar nicht.
Ich bin da in der, in der, in der Box.
Shop, Shop, da ist kein Break.
Zwischen Uhrzeit.
Hier, da muss nen, da muss nen Break rein.
Okay, jetzt stimmt's.
Hä? Jetzt hab ich da nen Break zu viel.
Wo kommt denn das jetzt her?
What the?
Can't wait. Wo kommt denn das jetzt her? Hier ist der Price.
Moment, es ist, es ist nen, es ist nen Shop Name, Case King.
Danach kommt nen diff, nen diff mit nem Preis.
So, da kommt nen Break.
Ah.
Ja, aber...
Muss ich, muss ich, muss ich sowas hier machen?
Sowas? Ah.
Excellent. So ist das doch fein, oder?
So ist das doch, so ist das doch preischampig.
Dann werden wir das noch einmal jetzt auf den Server schieben.
Weil jetzt öffnet er nämlich auch den Link in nem neuen Fenster, wenn man draufklickt.
Und macht die Seite nicht weg.
Dann deployen wir das jetzt noch einmal auf den Server drauf.
Mehr Versionen gebaut als auf der Arbeit in drei Jahren.
Gut, ist auch ein bisschen überschaubarer.
Und vor allem wieder was zu was umgebaut, was ich überhaupt nicht machen wollte.
So. SCP.
Oh Mist. Ah.
Der Preischamp muss ausgesch...
Und der Preischamp ist aus? Ist der Preischamp abgekackt? Vielleicht.
Ist der Preischamp gecrashed?
Oder hab ich den vorhin ausgemacht?
Ja, jetzt ist er down. Ich bin aber dumm, ich hab das Tab zugemacht.
Ich wollte den ja auch ausschalten.
Dass ich den Preischamp wieder anmachen kann.
Ok, jetzt machen wir ihn gleich wieder an, sobald die neue Version da ist.
SCP bestes Deployment, das gibt's nix.
Man könnte R-Sync machen oder vielleicht nur die Änderung übertragen, aber nope.
Solange wir pro Stunden bezahlt werden, machen wir das nicht.
Ok, Preischamp ist wieder da.
Hä? Chat, jetzt ist es richtig nice.
Oh. Websocket mag nicht.
Ah, mag er wieder.
Ok, aber es reicht mit 8 Kern. Das ist ok, der kann crawlen und kann die Anwendung ganz gut laufen lassen.
Guck mal da. Alternate verfügbar, 30,90.
Bam, direkt einkaufen.
Wo ist das Favicon? Da.
Ein richtiger Schnapper, ein richtiger Schnapper, es wird ja immer besser.
Easy.
Ob Media Markt.
Ok, da muss der Chat leider ran. Der Chat muss heute Nacht für mich Captures lösen, dass es weiter funktioniert.
Kein Boot.
Aber es stimmt, dass es lieferbar ist.
So Leute, Preischamp am Start.
IPv6? Hat es keinen IPv6?
Der Server hat doch IPv6.
Oder nicht? Doch.
Das müsste erreichbar sein über IPv6.
Oder beinet sich der Kadi nicht an IPv6.
Nicht erreichbar über IPv6.
Ah, ich hab den DNS-Rekord nicht gesetzt.
Keck, wait.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt noch nie public IPv6 DNS-Records gesetzt.
Das ist die richtige IP, ne?
Ich kann mal einen Triple, kann ich mal.
Nicht Triple-A, Quartruple-A.
Muss mal kurz mich einloggen.
Mist, ich hab mich vertippt.
L?
Alles klar.
Ok, also das da ist die DNS. Ich mach mal einen DNS-Preischamp-Org.
DNS-A-A-A-Rekord-Beta-Preischamp.
Ok, es sollte eigentlich gehen.
Dick-Beta.Preischamp.Org at 8888.
Äh, würde der mir jetzt eigentlich standardmäßig schon IPv6 ausgehen, wenn er einen hätte?
Probieren wir mal, oder muss ich ihm explizit abfragen?
Ok, ich muss ihm explizit abfragen.
Minus 6, genau, ja.
Gibt's net.
Noch net, aber ich hab's eingetragen.
Noch nicht.
Noch nicht, Leute, aber bald.
Wollte ich grad sagen. Man kann nämlich Dick explizit fragen.
Ja, genau.
Beta.Preischamp.Org.
Ok, es hat er noch nicht gecheckt.
Aber ich hab den DNS-Eintrag gemacht, also...
Kann sich nur noch um Stunden handeln, bis er's gecheckt hat.
Doch, ich kann den DNS aber explizit nach dem Record fragen, dass das funktioniert.
Also, sollte eigentlich funktionieren.
Aber ihr könnt's ja mal ausprobieren, ob's tut.
Ich kann's von hier nicht ausprobieren.
Ich kann's von hier nicht ausprobieren, ob die Adresse funktioniert.
Ich komm da nicht drauf, aber...
Vielleicht gibt's eine Online-Seite, wo ich das ausprobieren kann.
Test-Seite.
Ja, gut.
FeelsBadMan.
Vielleicht braucht es einfach. Also, ich hab's eingetragen.
Ich hab's eingetragen. Vielleicht geht's ja morgen mit IPv6.
Warum hab ich so eine Auslastung gerade?
Ah, weil ich lokal den Kram noch laufen hatte.
Alter!
Das russische Botnet ist wieder am Start hier.
Guckt's euch an!
Die Hacker-Mens wieder.
Also, das find ich ja nicht so geil. Ich mein, darf ich vergessen?
Der Krämpel.
Passt. Probiert mal, ob ihr IPv6 aufmachen könnt jetzt.
Ich mein, der Kram kostet 35 Euro im Monat.
Ja, gut, aktuell kommt man nicht drauf, weil der Server am Abkacken ist.
Der Server ist im Arsch.
Ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, was das soll, weil...
Ich mein, es ist halt schon recht teuer.
Da sollte das auch ordentlich funktionieren.
Guckt's euch mal an.
Macht jetzt gar nichts mehr.
Jetzt ist RIP, jetzt vorbei.
Also, wenn morgen in den Nachrichten kommt, hätt's ne RZ.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Wir müssen mal gucken, ob...
Dass der zu... Dass der irgendwie einen riesen Load hat.
Ich glaub, ich bin grad einfach auf einem falschen ESX-Cluster gelandet oder so.
Kannst du ne Counter anbauen für Zugriffe? Ja, kann man alles machen, aber...
Wo sieht man den Graph-Overview?
Kannst du das?
Ja, kann ich.
Ich mein, guck, bei Google geht's auch.
Aber ich glaub, der DNS hat sie nicht gecheckt.
Nö, da geht's nicht. Komisch.
Graphs? Nee. Networking?
Ach, da. Lul.
Hat ein bisschen was zu tun, aber mein, was willst du machen?
Hat aber eigentlich noch Luft.
Ah, jetzt geht er wieder.
Okay, nee, Leute.
Ich bin auf einem falschen ESX gelandet bei denen.
Na, das ist normal.
Guck, hier ist es auch wieder.
Der Preis-Champ ist am Start.
Ist auch eigentlich ne nice Übersicht.
Na ja, natürlich ist da noch Luft.
Der ist bei 600%
und ich hab acht CPU-Kerne. Also easy.
Da ist noch Luft.
Und jetzt ist er abgekackt. Jetzt muss er erst mal alles nachholen.
Jetzt muss er erst mal alles nachholen hier.
Was er eben noch nicht, was er eben nicht ausprobiert hat.
Was hat man für ne Load?
Nee, das ist okay.
Siebener Load bei acht Kerne, ist in Ordnung.
Ja, ist in Ordnung.
Der muss jetzt den ganzen Kram nachholen, weil er jetzt beim Lack nicht hinterher gekommen ist.
Zack, zack.
Und wie findet ihr den Preis-Champ, Leute?
PC King!
Ich glaub, ich war noch nie auf der Seite drauf.
Wie gesagt, da fehlt ja alles an Features, weil ich noch einbauen wollte.
Ich hab das heute Mittag nur in dreieinhalb Stunden zusammengewurstet.
Und jetzt halt im Stream noch ein bisschen gebastelt.
Dass es prinzipiell funktioniert.
Ich mein, ich hab ja ne lokale Datenbank mit den Preisen und alles.
Gibt's noch responsive?
Ey, guck mal, das Design ist mega responsive.
Guck dir das mal an. Siehst du das?
Hier.
Also wenn das nicht responsive ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ja gut, das geht halt nicht, aber okay.
Das ist poggers responsive.
PWA?
Ich hab mir schon überlegt, ob ich ne PWA mache.
Das Problem ist, dass PWAs auf iOS sacken.
Auf Android könnte man's machen.
Check mal, ob dein Server auf diesem Cloud-Node läuft.
Schau mal, wenn ich jetzt wüsste, wo man das sieht.
Wo sieht man das, auf welchem Cloud-Node ich laufe?
Sie können ihren Cloud-Server in der Cloud-Konsole...
Ach da, ne, da mach ich jetzt nix drin herum.
Da lieg ich bestimmt wieder irgendwelche IPs und Sachen und gedönns.
Ja, aber mit PWAs auf Android wird's funktionieren.
Auf iOS ist so ein Ding.
Auf iOS kannst du keine Push-Notifications schicken.
Und PWA im Hintergrund geht auch nicht.
Da geht bloß ne Native-App gescheit, aber das mach ich nicht für iOS.
Da muss ich mir irgendwas anderes überlegen.
Die Leute sollen sich dann einfach im Zweifelsfall Telegram-Notifications oder sowas einrichten,
worüber sie Notifications empfangen können.
So, Preis-Champ am Start.
Excellent.
Chat, nice, dass so viele am Start waren.
Ich werd jetzt mal in Ruhe was essen.
Ich lass den Preis-Champ oben.
Wo fragst du die Preise ab, bei irgendwie 20 verschiedenen Shops?
Ich lass den Preis-Champ oben und morgen guck ich mal, was so an Traffic verursacht hat
und wie groß die Datenbank ist und schauen wir mal.
Und dann werd ich die Tage bisschen mehr dran rumbasteln noch.
Ja, also.
Für mehr Responsiveness.
Das mach ich das nächste Mal.
Ich kopier's mir.
Wenn morgen ne Nachricht kommt, hätt's ne RZ abgebrannt.
Da wisst ihr, woran's gelegen hat.
Der Preis-Champ war aktiv.
Und verursacht, ähm, na ja, recht ordentlich CPU-Low, Network.
Also, guck mal, wir sehen doch jetzt schon, was es für Netzwerk-Traffic verursacht.
Das können wir noch mal kurz hochrechnen.
Also, wir haben circa 30 MB die Sekunde.
Das erscheint mir jetzt ein bisschen viel.
Oder sind das Bit?
Oh.
Okay, da sind MB.
30 MB die Sekunde.
Das ist schon ein bisschen, was?
BWM-NG, das kenn ich noch gar nicht, zeig mal.
Da können wir mal kurz hochrechnen, wie weit wir in unserem Treffel kommen.
Oh, das ist ja cool.
Okay, das sind Kilobyte.
Das sagt, kann man das umstellen in Megabyte?
Äh, Switch.
D.
MB.
Okay, also wir haben ungefähr 30 MB die Sekunde, sagen wir mal, Traffic.
Nennen wir mal 30 MB die Sekunde.
Das ist doch viel zu viel, na ja.
Das sind Webseiten heutzutage.
Jede Webseite, jede Webseite ist bestimmt mal so 2, 3 MB.
Outbound, also TX.
Ja, sagen wir mal 30, sagen wir mal 20, sagen wir mal 20.
Der lädt alles wie ein Chrome.
Die Seite ist, keine Ahnung, 2, 3 MB groß.
Und der macht jede Produktpage.
Der refrescht ohne Ende.
Also wir haben 20 MB die Sekunde.
Wir haben 20 MB die Sekunde.
Das sind 1.200, also 1,2 GB in der Minute.
Also das ist ordentlich.
Okay, mal 24, nee Moment, mal 60 in der Stunde.
Mal 24.
Okay.
Das sind 1, das sind 1, Moment ernsthaft?
Hab ich verrechnet?
Sind das 1,6 TB am Tag?
Ernsthaft?
Okay.
Ich glaube ich muss mir einen Cloud Provider mit mehr Bonus Traffic suchen.
Was gibt es denn bei dir 1 und 1 Cloud?
Die sind immer sonst so billig.
Traffic?
Oh, endlich Web Hosting.
Muscle Davis am Start, ja.
So.
Alles klar.
Traffic?
Hallo, wie viel Traffic ist da dabei?
Leute, seht ihr es irgendwo?
Wie viel?
Wo steht er?
Nee, der Traffic muss da dabei stehen.
Ich weiß wo wir hin wechseln morgen Leute.
Die kicken mich bestimmt nach einem Monat.
Okay, was kostet, was bezahlen wir denn hier?
6 Cores, das ist zu wenig.
Das ist zu wenig.
Ich will 16.
Okay, was ist Digital Ocean?
Traffic Pricing?
Das war glaube ich so ähnlich wie Hetzner.
Moment.
1TB nur, das reicht hinten vorne nicht.
Wieso?
Das kann doch sein.
Der fragt jede Produktseite ab.
Guck mal, wie schnell der das abfragt.
Der fragt pro Sekunde, keine Ahnung, der fragt pro Sekunde wahrscheinlich irgendwie 5 Seiten ab.
Und davon ist jede Seite irgendwie 3 MB oder so, das kommt schon hin.
Das kommt schon hin, der ist volle Pulle am Seitenladen.
Ich hoffe, wir können es ja mal ausprobieren.
Guck mal, ich mache jetzt mal aus.
Ich mache jetzt mal aus.
Und schon ist der Traffic weg.
Hast du den Low Bandwidth Mode mal probiert?
Ne.
Ob das was bringt?
Wahrscheinlich bringt das nichts.
Leute, in spätestens 10 Minuten bin ich weg.
Da muss ich nämlich noch was futtern.
Ich habe noch kein Abendessen richtig gefuttert.
Wie lange bin ich denn am Start hier?
5 Stunden.
Guck mal, solange man was Interessantes macht, geht die Zeit sau schnell rum.
Man kann die Anfragen leider nicht gescheit reduzieren.
Ich habe schon eingestellt, dass er die einzelnen Shopseiten nur jede Minute bis 2 Minuten abfragt.
Das ist nicht so Big Brain gemacht.
Also, wisst ihr was?
Wir kommen mit 6 Kernen aus.
Wir kommen mit 6 Kernen aus und dann mieten wir uns einfach bei 1&1 was.
Was kostet der Kram?
Okay, was kostet es, wenn ich das pro Monat nehme?
Linux?
Cloud Backup braucht keiner.
Wer braucht Cloud Backup?
Vertragslaufzeit 1 Monat.
Was?
Ach so.
Ja, okay.
Ich spar halt die Hälfte für 6 Monate.
Ich muss mich mal morgen schlau machen, was man da schön nehmen kann.
Oh Leute.
Die.
Das Botnet ist wieder am Start.
DDoS ist raus wieder.
Guck mal hier, wie viele Pings da verloren gehen unterwegs.
Ob das was damit zu tun hat, wenn ich das an und aus mache, kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Das hatte der doch vorher auch nicht.
Lohnt es sich eine Informatik zu machen oder reicht eine Ausbildung?
Kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Guck mal, wie es hängt.
Ich werde über DDoS Mitigation geroutet.
Ja gut, die Dinger heißen wahrscheinlich alle so.
Nee, das liegt nicht daran.
Vorher mit drei Cores lief der Server stabiler.
Ich glaube, ich bin irgendwie im falschen RZ und hätte halt gerade Probleme oder so.
Ich hoffe, wir haben es gleich.
Weil so kannst du das ja nicht verwenden.
Ich will jetzt bloß noch mal wissen, ob es jetzt besser funktioniert.
Ich habe schon mein Brain leckt.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, was wir umgestellt haben.
Was haben wir jetzt gerade umgestellt?
Warum habe ich es jetzt neu gestartet?
Ach so, Low Bandwidth Mode.
Genau.
Guckt euch mal, wie lahm das antwortet.
Ja, dann machen wir morgen mal weiter.
Wenn das jetzt ich will warten, bis der jetzt endlich mal noch mal hingekriegt hat.
Macht er ja nichts.
Der ist schon längst wieder.
Leute, der läuft im Hintergrund schon längst wieder.
Der ist es runtergegangen auf 10 MB.
Okay, jetzt halten wir es einen Monat aus bei Hetzner, Leute.
Jetzt halten wir es einen Monat aus.
Oh.
Ja, jetzt sind wir bei 8 MB.
Jetzt halten wir es einen Monat aus, aber der Preis-Cham geht nicht.
Preis-Cham ist down.
Outgoing geht anscheinend.
Outgoing geht anscheinend, aber das ist auch etwas im Arsch.
Die Webseite ist im Arsch.
Hetzner hat irgendwelche Probleme gerade.
Da kann ich nichts machen.
Guckt mal hier, ich kriege auch keinen Ping mehr durch auf die Kiste.
Kann man irgendwie sagen, ich will anders geroutet werden oder so?
Wir können auch Loadbalancer davor machen, das wird es jetzt aber auch nicht bringen.
Ja, es kommt drauf an, wo man halt drüber geht.
Am Anfang ging ja auch, am Anfang war ja auch alles gut.
Ah, guck mal, es geht wieder.
Aber zwischenzeitlich ist SSH abgekackt, nice.
SSH.
Excellent, das immer wieder.
Preis-Cham geht auch wieder.
Oder auch nicht.
Oh nee, ist wieder abgekackt.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr.
Dafür bezahle ich doch kein Geld.
Also ernsthaft.
The fuck?
Kann doch nicht den hier ernst sein jetzt.
Der Preis-Cham muss preisen.
Der kann nicht down sein.
Guck mal, jetzt geht es mal wieder kurz.
Jetzt geht es wieder nicht.
Ok, zumindest geht es besser.
Guck mal, der Preis-Cham geht wieder.
Und jetzt geht er wieder nicht.
Boah, ey.
Kann doch nicht sein.
Geht die Seite bei euch?
Ja, geht, alles gut.
Aber guck mal, der Low-Bandwidth-Mode bringt was.
Da kommen wir jetzt einen Monat mit aus.
Nein, ich belaste die Leitung nicht zu stark.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Was wäre das für ein Cloud-Ambitor,
wo du das mit einem Software hinkriegst?
Nein, das hat auf gar keinen Fall.
Ok, nice.
Leute, ich lasse es jetzt bis morgen laufen.
Ich lasse es bis morgen laufen.
Ihr könnt ja ein bisschen mit Preis-Chamen noch.
Gucken, wie es so läuft.
Ihr dürft jetzt einmal raten,
wie viele Subs habe ich heute.
Wer richtig liegt, der gewinnt einen Sub.
Oder darf sich jemand aussuchen,
der einen Sub bekommt.
Wer regelmäßig da ist und mitzählt,
der weiß natürlich besser Bescheid.
Der Preis-Chamen, jawoll.
Wie findet ihr eigentlich den Domain-Name?
Also ich finde, Preis-Chamen hat was, oder?
Nice.
Ok, Leute.
Stopp.
Aus ist genug.
Probiert.
Genug geraten.
Ab hier ist Schluss.
Ich habe 342.
Mal gucken, ob einer richtig war.
Nope.
Noch nicht mal even close.
Nö, da ist ja gar keiner in der Nähe.
xDxDxD hat 345.
xDxDxD hat 345, ok.
Das ist in Ordnung.
Du darfst dir einen aussuchen,
der einen Sub kriegt, der noch keinen hat.
Das ist aber näher dran.
338 ist 4 weg und 335 ist 3 weg.
xDxDxD hat es verdient.
Der ist öfters da.
Den habe ich auch schon gesehen.
Der hat es auf jeden Fall verdient.
Zack, Sub.
Aber verschenken.
Auf geht's.
Exquisite.
Leute.
So.
Jetzt war mal Schluss.
Ich esse jetzt noch schnell was.
Dann gehe ich ins Bett.
Mal gucken, ob ich wieder arbeite.
Ihr könnt ja mal ein Auge auf den Preis-Champ haben.
Aber der Preis-Champ ist sehr nice.
Vor allem die Domain.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft, das will ich euch mal fragen.
Wie findet ihr die Domain?
Ich habe jetzt gar nicht gesehen.
Habt ihr irgendwas schon dazu gesagt?
Was ist das denn für eine Poggers Seite?
Die haben wir heute im Stream gemacht.
Das ist beta-preis-champ.org.
Domain ist Poggers, ja.
Sehr gut.
Kann man sich auch gut merken, ne?
Hippo-Startup-Tourneil-Domain.
Ich habe mir auch schon...
Wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich mir auf Twitter...
Preis-Champ?
Ah, habe ich nicht.
Doch, habe ich.
Lull.
Habe ich.
Ich habe es unbenannt in...
Hä?
Ist das nicht frei?
Okay, jetzt ist es eh zu spät.
Jetzt wird es mir eh weggecrapped.
Jetzt ist es eh vorbei.
Also Leute.
Machts gut, wir sehen uns.
Ich hau ab.
Bis denn.
Tschüss.